the entire
portland police riot squad has resigned
apparently one of these cops struck an
activist photographer
i guess the establishment politicians
were like you attacked the press
and they're like dude that guy's a
writer pretending to be the press
and uh i guess the the immediate
response
and the best response was probably
michael malus is when he waved his arms
in the air as
like ron paul yelling that it was
happening yeah it's great
me and luke were very happy to hear this
christmas christmas
um but it isn't actually i i think
you're right i i it's a joke when we're
like it's happening but think about it
it was only a matter of time before the
police were like dude these people are
rioters and the politicians were like
shut up do as you're told and they said
we quit
right that's big well it's also uh
as someone who is a big proponent of uh
casting aspersions on the police both as
a group and as individuals
part of the reason behind that strategy
is that as the cost of anything
increases the cost of a car the cost of
a book cost of soda
at a certain point some people are like
i can't afford this book i can't afford
this soda
and for police that's gonna be like why
am i putting up with
being disrespected if not contempt
okay maybe i'm putting up with it
because i'm making my neighborhood a
better place
i'm helping my family like i get it this
is politics and i'm the whipping boy at
the moment fine
but at a certain point it's like wait
wait i'm gonna get treated like crap
and i can't do the base level job like
rioting is like something that's
unambiguous this isn't like selling
lucy's or
jaywalking it's like this is 101 cop
stuff that
i sign up for so i don't i'm i'm shocked
and delighted that uh no that they're
giving up their pensions
because listen anyone who has a job i'm
going to speak positively about the cops
now and honestly anyone has a job in a
family it is really
damn hard to be like i quit yeah like
you have to give people credit for
walking the walk and talking to talk
it's it's not all good news mr mouse
we've got some other stories the
mccloskeys have agreed to give up their
guys haven't been deported so yeah of
course oh right right
sure well the mccloskeys are giving up
their guns it's kind of not that big a
deal because i guess they're not felons
they can go buy more but man
is it screwed up that their guns were
taken in the first place
and that's it's a bad sign but there
there are some positives ahead i think
one of the things uh that michael mouse
will be talking about is the the mises
caucus and dave smith
and uh press secretary michael mallis so
we're gonna have a very very fun
conversation
around that uh so we can get some energy
yeah yes
you make sure you you drink up that
caffeine michael thanks for thinking
he's got pizza as well
and uh uh we're gonna talk a lot about
uh michael's also got a book we'll get
into
sir we're also hanging out with of
course lukowski so that's a lot of
aspartame you got there and
howdy this is your humble t-shirt vendor
with the latest t-shirt that says people
will forget your words
people will forget your accomplishments
but no one will forget you voted for joe
biden
which you could exclusively get on
thebestpoliticoshirts.com
and thanks so much for having me i also
have a youtube channel we are change
so yeah that's right dude and i'm ian
crossland what's up everybody glad to
see you michael i'm so glad you're back
i'm so excited to hear about your book
man it's great i don't know if we'll
get into your experience in north korea
at all tonight
thank you very much that's the wrong
language i speak not have you been there
to korea yeah yes to north korea no then
you don't like but
i wrote the book my great grandfather is
from there i heard he wrote a tiger
that's right that's right
this is uh inside i guess it's an inside
joke people are going to be like what
are you talking about
anyway that's all i had to say i love
you jim thanks for having me
right on i am also here in the corner
pushing buttons this is always fun
we always have a blast with michael
mouse i'm really excited
that this news is breaking when he's
here oh and shouting out to adrian and
jesse who are i'm sure in the chat room
right on how's it going
well we got a great sponsor today my
friends check the link in the
description below for
surfing internetsafe.com and you can get
a vpn
virtual shields virtual private network
30
off for life they say this work is a
little
complicated but right here you can start
now for free and enjoy 24 months of
online security from the world's easiest
and fastest vpn for only 83.83
that's actually 68 off but you'll get 30
percent of all add-ons
and other great discounts on all their
other plans it comes out to only about
3.49 per month uh in the long run
now a vpn a virtual private network it
it helps
obfuscate your browsing so nefarious
actors
criminals hackers governments makes it a
lot harder for that for them to spy on
you
the way i always describe it for those
that are familiar with this ad read is
it's like
you know we don't expect people to break
into our houses but we lock our doors we
lock our windows and that's what a vpn
provides for you there's a bunch of
other really cool things you can do with
the vpn because
when you log into your vpn you can
choose which country you appear from
which
has interesting impacts on some things
around the world i can't say those in an
ad read but
just look at what vpns can do they're
really cool services and tools they help
protect you they keep you safe they give
you
mobility in terms of certain
restrictions i'll put it that way
so again go in the link the links in the
description below surfing
internetsafe.com virtual shield
was my first sponsor they've been
sponsors of all of my shows
going way back to the beginning of my
youtube career
so uh i gotta say this would not be
possible without them supporting my work
for the entirety of how long i've been
on youtube independently so
i'm eternally grateful again surfing
internetsafe.com and i'm gonna say one
more thing people always complain about
all these different corporations who are
like
subject to vocalism and are scared of
getting cancelled well this is the
positive alternative which is when you
support the outlets that support the
creators you like
you're not doing charity you're getting
something for it and something that's a
quality product
and then you can feel good about
yourself so i've got sponsor you've got
sponsors
and i feel just like you they've been
with you for a long time i feel
happy to promote them because they're
putting their money where their mouth is
and they're taking a risk to some extent
by supporting someone who like if i was
tied or someone of these horrible
conglomerates i would find radioactive
you pointed all this sodas
well um well in that regard i've got
some other news too go to timcast.com
become a member
because you'll get something for your
membership you get exclusive members
only segments and there will be one
which goes up around 11 pm after every
show every night
but you're not just getting access to
this to this wonderful members only
stream
we recently brought on cassandra
fairbanks to lead our newsroom
michael mouse is super excited
cassandra's fantastic
yes she's getting a monkey she's getting
a monkey no no no don't do it
don't do oh my god no no no no no no
cassandra don't don't already tweet it
out
it's too late no no no no no no no no no
no she's getting it right now
oh no no no don't baby now
look okay let's let's get through this
right now let's get real let's get
serious this
i got attacked by monkeys in thailand
before giraffe
okay this is
hippo oh wow my mammoth with mammoths
yeah yeah yeah
i know a lot about zoology and killing
animals oh my pat benatar
the 80s uh singer who's amazing she had
an autobiography
uh and i read it it's very good there's
one sentence
she grew up in greenpoint brooklyn which
you would know very well
and she goes when i was in junior high
school we had a monkey and i i'm talking
like tim now i'm doing like my tim
cadence there you go and i'm sitting
there reading it as someone's a
co-author of books and i said
oh for the ghostwriter whose name is on
the cover i go
if you're interviewing someone to write
their book and they say oh we had a
monkey
that's a chapter because because
every day when pat benatar comes home
there's something with this effing
monkey
like the monkey's getting into places
it's it's pleasuring itself
it's raping the monkeys are not good
pets
right it's too late michael she's gotten
yeah and on the friends reunion
when david truman was asked what was the
one thing you liked least about the show
he said this
monkey wow because i had to interact
with it like we'd do a whole scene
and then the monkey just not doing its
thing we had to do it from the scratch
that's why they got rid of marcel in
that show i'm more excited about the
monkey now
i really oh i was i was actually more
excited that cassandra's going to be
writing stories to the website and
leading a team and bringing
people this is a big mistake dude she's
getting a monkey
it's not it's awesome on paper they're
horrible pets
well you'll have to uh uh talk to her
about it we'll have to put it
it's too late though she's gotten the
monkey it's not too late to put it down
has she named the monkey
uh i don't know actually i think so i
think so
but anyway the point i was gonna make
was that when you're a member of
timcast.com the money that goes
in to from your membership is going
towards hiring more journalists so i
just had a
call and a conversation with some
journalists we're going to be poaching
some journalists from some other
companies you know and love because
that's the way the market works i guess
and uh we're going to be making sure
that we can support these people so like
your membership is going to go
to make sure that real journalists are
getting paid so they can live and they
can actually do the good work
and uh if you saw the bonus segment yes
i did ask ivory if she wanted a job but
you know we'll see how things play out
i'm not i don't want to do like a big
show where it's like oh this journalist
is not looking for work let me make it a
thing
let me talk something else to build what
you just said on i i don't know for a lo
you remember i'm sure there was that cnn
piece where brian stelter had some kind
of media express
very on and they were not mentioning you
by name but they were specifically
complaining like there's these youtube
shows that are new shows
and their audience is like 10 times the
size of ours what are we gonna do about
this
the point why they're right to be upset
even if your show was a tenth the size
of brian's or
one percent if you're having someone
with a different point of view
and something that's coherent and
comports to reality that is going to
punch way above its numbers in terms of
destroying the corporate media narrative
right because if you have you know new
york times blah blah it's going to have
its stuff
and then one person comes along goes
this story is actually bullcrap
just like my book on amazon it's the
same as barack obama's book you just get
your own page
that journalist its article is going to
look on tim catch just like an article
in new york times
and people be able to make their own
informed choices now yep so good for you
we're also going to be hiring fact
checkers to work independently out of a
different office
so if someone here writes an article uh
someone else at a different office who's
not in communication will then read the
article and then say
let me check this how much those i i
need a fact checker for my next book
okay good to know but we're gonna be
hiring staff fact checkers are gonna
make phone calls they're going to
basically redo the story to make sure
on our end we're doing real journalism
okay of course there's been a lot of
activist groups that are really outraged
by cassandra but this is what your
membership is getting
it's getting people like cassandra for
all her feistiness on twitter she's
doing great journalism she
is amazing i got some exciting plans she
really is i'm going to hire the monkey
to write for we are change.org
and give it some cigarettes and
it's going to be nice i forgot what it's
called it's small
oh yeah okay those are better they're
like squirrels very small but they're
very
uh erratic so uh i i if people aren't
familiar with cassandra she writes for
gateway and i'm not a fan of gateway
oh like at all okay and because you like
a lot of their articles it's like
sensationalists like really over the top
yeah you don't want to have like like a
video with a big crazy headline right
but cassandra her articles are really
straightforward research she calls for
comments she does
it's fantastic so we're going to be
bringing that in and we're going to be
bringing more people in so and i think
it's great that you're in a position to
not that i'm i'm just going to spend two
hours blog smoke up your ass but i get
it
i i think it's great that when you're
hiring someone they're not some milk
toast i'm not going to name names people
on twitter
but she's a brawler oh yeah so if they
start coming for her it's not like she's
going to be like let me talk to my
editor she's like
okay we can do this nps i have a monkey
now
right my attitude is like you know what
i say
i'm not going to name the person who but
you can see it on twitter started
tweeting like
some you know bold moves by the beanie
compound or whatever and quoting
cassandra
and i'm like these activists are
engaging in a harassment campaign
against my female journalists
yeah like and i was like you don't get
to as a single mom
yeah exactly you don't get to go on the
new york times and complain about
journalism
and women in journalism specifically
exactly exactly anyway this is a really
long promo but uh
hey timcast.com be a member and help
support the expansion because
paranormal shows coming next the we've
been talking about for a while
so we're getting this like a this is a
really great writer that we're talking
to right now his stuff's fantastic and
it's like deep
academic view and research into crazy
stories and paranormal research
none of this ghost hunting like oh i got
an evp like i want legit scientific
we compared you know control groups i
want legit here's the history of the old
haunted house and what we found out
about it
real cool stuff and we're going to do a
podcast and cassandra's going to be
involved in that as well do you want to
know the story of number 13 berkeley
square
yeah what is that let's get started i
guess sure it's a ghost story but it's
it's this is my favorite ghost story
because i
then it reflect it reflects on me
personally when i was a kid there was a
book of ghost stories i read
and they talked about number 13 berkeley
square and the point being it was it's a
very famous neighbor very rich
neighborhood now
there were a couple of sailors there in
like the 1800s any port in a storm
they it was supposed to be haunted and
one guy's like all right
if you get scared ring this bell and you
know whatever
they separate the guy hears the bell
ringing
he goes upstairs to see his friend and
the friend is dead with the look of
horror on it
look taran's face people who visit the
house said the walls were
this is i love as an author like
interesting phrasing
they said the walls were filled with
electric horror
when i was an adult my favorite author
is e nesbit she's a british children's
novelist
um i ordered a manuscript that was ever
published
and it turned out that it was a
bookstore that
is number 13 berkeley square i'm like oh
my oh my god i thought this when i was a
kid he goes
i could give you the tour that room is
like a broom closet so
it's kind of spooky because it's small
but it's not haunted but
that's the story number 13 berkeley
square there's something well no there's
a couple of people who died of horror
like and there was like no cause for it
there's something about the electric i
think
phantom dna where they bombard dna in a
vacuum with electrons and then they
remove the dna and the electrons stay
there as if the
dna is still there for like two weeks or
longer
i mean and so i think this goes yeah i
love stories like this
right so that's the plan man that's
awesome yeah so we're gonna
we're gonna be having someone who's
dedicated to that kind of production and
then we wanna make a cool mystery spooky
paranormal stuff
basically i view it as kind of just like
a a
research into the unknown you know what
i mean so i'm not i don't necessarily
believe in ghosts
i just say well there's interesting
stories but i think all these ghost
hunter shows just make crap
up like there's one exception so i met
the guy who was like the ep on jesse
ventura's show
and or maybe he was i don't want to out
the god wherever he was in the show and
i said
how many of these stories are real he's
like yeah okay it's all crap uh but he's
like he came in with an open mind being
like okay is this real or is it not and
everything was like okay there's nothing
he said skinwalker ranch he goes that i
don't know what the hell was going on
there but that stuff is real so that is
like the real area 51 that people don't
know about it's getting back
i think they made a show about it now
but this was like five or six years
we've
we actually one of our first segments we
ever did on the show is about skin
walking ranch
what is it do you know do you have i
don't i no please tell me
i don't know it's been a long time since
it's apparently like this place where
they have private like air stuff
and it's like no one's allowed near it
and it's just there's a lot of weird
stuff having to do it because it's like
there's this one guy
who has a monopoly license that no one
else in the country has
this is all like playing telephone i'm
completely garbling the story people can
look it up themselves
but there was it's one of those like
bohemian grove where there's like lots
of questions and
surely there's some kind of logical
answer but on the face of it it's like
this is weird weird stuff
i just googled it and there's a breaking
news story from two days ago
this is allegedly alleged ufo sighting
at skinwalker ranch brandon frugal's
eyewitness account on jessup's journal
so apparently at skinwalk range there's
like a bunch of weird sightings
creepy creatures ufos and stuff we have
a story from this is an nbc story
they say uh abc i'm sorry says abc4
there are some things that can't be
explained in this episode of utah
success stories you'll see a preview
blah blah blah
okay legend has it that supernatural
activities occur on a piece of land
surrounded by the ut indian reservation
is it ut
in the uh unta what is it what is a ute
that is that what it is my cousin vinnie
sorry oh okay
there's two it's you in time i remember
that joke
brandon fruit fugal bought the land five
years ago and brought in a team of
scientists to see if the legends were
true
what's the the thing that he knows now
that he didn't know before surprised him
the most
i i bought the ranch as a skeptic as a
healthy skeptic i had never seen a ufo
a ghost or an orb or anything of the
sort in my life and i disclosed it to
the previous donor
vogel claims that he and his team have
experienced unexplained phenomena yeah
i was surprised at how open he was and
he told me those first six months of
owning it i really saw nothing myself
that would lead me to believe that there
was anything unusual
well that all changed i had with
multiple witnesses with me on occasion
where we saw what can only be described
as an unidentified flying object a craft
a 40 50 foot long silver disc hovering
right above the mesa
right in front of us this wasn't just
blinking light in the sky or something
that was a little bit ambiguous
this was a solid object that appeared
out of nowhere and
nowhere could move in the blink of an
eye and over a 20-second period perform
maneuvers
that i believe defy any propulsion
physics propulsion physics that were
acquainted with it
so there's a lot of stories like this i
don't know if i actually think this
website is meant to just like promote
something related to a show
sounds like it but it's the other thing
i want to point out my dad was like
excuse my grandfather was an aircraft
controller in the soviet union uh i told
the story of the shows
so he was really high up and i asked him
about ufos he goes we saw this kind of
stuff all the time
and the thing people don't appreciate is
it's really easy to be like oh this is
some guy who was drunk in the middle of
the field
it's like no no these are professionals
who on a day-to-day basis interact with
all kinds of aircraft who are
doing military so they know what the
american capabilities are and their
capabilities
to this day aren't what these people are
saying my grandfather's like we saw this
all the time yeah and there's like i'm
not saying it's aliens but i'm like
he's like it's not nothing there's
reports of these ever since world war
ii so they've been going on for a long
time there's there's been this media
push
surrounding china or russia having
advanced military technology and this is
why we need to bolster the the
military-industrial complex
we've been hearing that talk but if if
this has been going on
since world war ii there's no way russia
or china could develop that kind of
technology all the way back then
so that theory that the mainstream media
is trying to push out there as we're
waiting for the disclosure to come up by
the pentagon
any freaking day now is absolutely false
on many merits
first of all please don't call the
mainstream because you know they're
depraved and not part of the mainstream
they're corporate
and number two is i want to say some
other words but but
they won't be family friendly uh my
understanding is that after the soviet
union fell apart and a lot of these
files declassified there were a lot of
documentation in the soviet union where
they were like they thought these are
american vessels they were seeing
because they're like
we don't have anything that's like this
this must be the americans where the
americans have so both sides assumed
there's the other because they knew okay
it's not us it's not our allies but but
after world war ii there was a time
a short period where the united states
and russia talked to each other and they
were talking to each other specifically
about these unidentified flying objects
that are defying the laws of science
so we even see the diplomatic
communications between those two
countries saying hey
is this you no is this you know what's
going on here we don't know and then the
cold war
hit its kind of precipice and then
things got severe and then diplomatic
communication stopped and uh we don't
know what's going on and
not to be all tin foil hat although i
still have alex's at my house
uh there is a very concerted effort uh
in
like corporate media so like don't look
outside look at the screens and look at
what we're telling you and anything
doesn't fit our narrative which is our
narrative is
we can explain everything for you go to
your couch turn on cnn turn on [ __ ]
whatever
we will tell you what the news is and
how to think about it since they don't
have a narrative here
it's going to be really tricky for them
so they're like oh it's all crazy people
or it's storks storks can't hover yeah
and the thing is i started one more
thing
sorry interrupted the guy who bought
this ranch if there's
eyewitnesses if there's four of them
they know the difference between a stork
and a 50-foot object
sorry it's getting weird yeah so a lot
of people think this big ufo talk
they're going to really
release this report is just a
distraction it's a it's an effort to
bolster
the military to preempt it yeah well
it's a distraction
from like the very serious problems that
are happening right now like was it
china
just flew 28 warplanes into the
taiwanese air defense zone
which is freaking everybody out the u.s
has got a strike group in the area then
russia does war games off hawaii
these things would scare people so then
what do they do they dangle a ufo and
they're like
look over here don't look at the war
that's that's potentially on the verge
of breaking out look at the ufo in the
sky and all the reports coming out
obama comes out and says it but it'll be
interesting because it is weird
yeah the first thing bill clinton did
when he came to the white house he says
it's a web hubble it's like find out
what happened with jfk and what's going
on with ufos
and then when he found out that his face
just turned pale or was he like laughing
he got introduced to jeffrey epstein
here's why they don't tell you about the
ufos yeah you go up to a ufo but you
come down to rapist
that's right no one wants that well yeah
apparently a few people do
i wonder if it's uh corporations there's
a big article by newsweek today that
actually talked about
bill clinton's relationship with mr
jeffrey epstein and
how it was uh obfuscated with prince
andrew
and how the whole prince andrew saga
according to a journalist that works on
the royal family
uh specifically very closely together
that
the whole thing that happened with
prince andrew was just at a distraction
so no one would pay attention to the
larger
bigger and longer relationship that bill
clinton had to
epstein i i am really impressed how he
went from your ghost story
to skinwalker ranch to ufos to epstein
there's like an amazing
segue here and this is newsweek
reporting this today which is absolutely
surprising that finally this is breaking
in the mainstream and this is widely
talked about
yeah and i find it absolutely important
because when you really
look at the true realms of of what has
been going on behind the scenes of
government
and now these people are saying trust us
we're going to tell you what what
happens with these aliens
you know there should be a lot of
skepticism at least i have
an absolutely amazing conspiracy theory
that i was reading uh the other day
it was on like uh reddit it was like a
it started with a 4chan post
i know i know i know the idiot had a
baby it's amazing
i love it it's like it's this absolutely
ridiculous 4chan post where someone's
claiming a bunch of things about
viruses merging with human dna thousands
of years ago
and what's really happening with the
ufos and what's going on but
i can't talk about it because youtube it
includes some of the taboo subjects
so as we'll do we'll save it for the
bonus segment it's it's dude it's like
it's the most ridiculous insane garbage
i've ever read however it would make an
awesome movie like the secret wars with
trump and like what's really happening
with the aliens and like
it's uh i guess i would call it chicken
coop theory what's that mean
that the earth is a chicken coop for
aliens it's a great theory oh yeah yeah
i've heard that
and that's the ufos are just basically
like you know when when i go out and i'm
wearing my boots and i'm like throwing
feed into the chicken area and the
chickens are like what's happening
there's a giant thing here what is it
that's how we are with these aliens and
so
but but i can't talk about it because it
includes
medical stuff and when they come
straight at us we can't see them so we
have to turn our head to see them
sideways but that's why people
see like flashes of light and things
they can't necessarily or it's
multi-dimensional because they keep
coming straight at us
it's a different dimension like alex was
saying but we'll we'll do a big bonus
segment on so we'll have a lot of fun
with it
let's jump into the actual like main
news and then
we got a lot to talk about so this story
is the it's happening
from the daily mail portland police's
entire riot squad resigns after cop was
indicted
for striking activist photographer who
they insist was a rioter
with baton during violent protest saw
government building
set uh government building satellite you
see the portland police union said the
officers would be leaving the squad in
response to the indictment on tuesday
of a member of member corey budworth
bardworth was charged with assault
related to an august 18-20 incident
in which he allegedly struck a
photographer terry jacobs of the baton
the police union said the officers were
set upon by 200 protesters
and that budworth had accidentally hit
jacobs in the head they have also
claimed jacobs was part of the riot
she was not charged with any crime and
was awarded a fifty thousand dollar
settlement by the city of portland over
the incident
despite the resignation the officers
officers would remain employed by the
portland police department
it's not clear how this will affect the
department's ability to respond to riots
you know what i really love how they say
it's the riot squad responding to
protests
yeah can we just say the riot squad
responds to riots yeah yeah
i guess they do respond to protests too
so they're not they're not quitting the
entire department
they just are refusing to go out during
riots anymore
and here's another thing in their
defense is that you see in a lot of
these places they arrest people and then
it's just a revolving door the
prosecutors aren't gonna do anything and
explicitly so so then it's like wait i
gotta get in the middle of this
drama i'm people are gonna be throwing
whatever at me
uh everyone's gonna hate me i'm gonna
arrest this person the person's gonna be
like just
walk right out the door like at the very
least like why am i putting in all this
effort
it's worse than that now and this is
what i love about it i've been going on
uh
people were tweeting at you because i
said abolish the police they were like
michael you've done such great work with
tim
that's true and uh but my my reason for
abolish the police is
not the same as yours i think okay uh
although i do think definitely
the conversations we've had have have
been influential to my opinions as well
i think the reason they should be
leaving is because they can't do their
jobs
functionally anymore i agree it's not so
we agree but you know i think you're
more of the
anarchists the police are bad across the
board i definitely agree with you on the
gun thing for sure that was like a good
a good argument
but what we're seeing now is not only
will the police
if they arrest someone nothing happens
to that person they're actually
arresting the cops now yeah that's
amazing imagine the kind of feckless
pathetic spineless jellyfish cop you'd
have to be
to turn around and arrest your own cop
who was doing literally what the
what the city told them to do well that
guy's a hero because that means that
those cops are enforcing a consultation
law should be arrested right so those
guys so then what happens is one by one
they'll start arresting each other i i
mean i don't i don't know
one by one but in all seriousness like
yeah i
obviously i'm no friend of the police
and i i always say and i will defend
that every cop is a criminal but at a
certain point
it's just like you feel i'm sure
the vast majority of people who are
police officers feel all right that's a
tough job
someone's got to do it and i'm really
helping people i'm stopping murders i'm
stopping rapists like little kids are
not getting
snatched yeah it sucks but someone's got
to do it i'm doing a good job of it
at a certain point if in any gig like if
you had ian here and you're like ian you
can only talk for 30 seconds every hour
it's at a certain point it's like why am
i even here like
what am i doing here right so it's the
same thing it's like i have this job and
i have my fantasy or my you know ideal
version of what it's going to be
and my boss is not only not allowing me
to do it
but it's taking steps for preventing me
to do it it's just like how much respect
do you have for me i'm getting crapped
down by the people on the street i'm
going to crap them on my boss and my
colleagues
how am i going to have dignity for my
home but let's take it one step further
let's say please let's take as many as
possible here's what i mean let's say
you know like luke's luke's joining us
on the show
you know he comes in periodically
imagine if i said here's the only things
you're allowed to talk about
make it really really difficult for him
and then then he actually does
what i tell him to do and i get mad
because it just for some reason caused
me a problem so i lock him in the
basement
and you publish no no that's that's
insane and publicly denounce him that's
the other no no
no no no no no no no i'm serious because
i know these cops names are public
so that means they're no they're known
in the in by all their neighborhood
that i got arrested for doing my job
that's not going to feel nice well how
dare you equate me to a cop
first of all second of all the police
union chief had a very interesting
comment he said our
rt rrt members do not volunteer to have
molotov cocktails fireworks explosives
rocks bottles urine feces and other
dangerous objects thrown at them
they do he noted that the team members
volunteer for the work without any
specific
pay so these members are stepping down
out of this response unit the mayor
uh wheeler asked him please don't do
this don't do this
and and then the police responded well
too bad we're doing this anyway
uh after of course all the you know
major political decisions that have been
happening in portland
now here's here's the best part imagine
um i asked luke to come on the show
i then say here's the only things you're
allowed to say then
even when he just does what i asked i
publicly denounce him
luke instead of quitting the show says
well
i won't talk about foreign policy
anymore and he keeps coming to the show
these cops they're resigning from the
riot squad right and they're staying
with the city
staying under the boot of the corrupt
system that's literally trying to put a
cop in jail
because they sent him out at a riot i
was trying to talk nice about the cops
you're making it harder
oh no i i won't have it man i've been
saying for a while you know that woman
um in in minnesota she shot the the guy
he was he was a a wanted felon for a gun
charge or armed robbery
what was her name kimberly potter and
potter yeah this was during the chauvin
trial
she was trying to she was going for a
taser and then she pulled her gun on
accident
she shoots the guy yeah that's yeah okay
i said i hope good
prison right to prison because
negligence yeah well there's two things
one is
you are responsible for anything that
comes out of your gun period however if
she actually shot him should have been
justified not that i'm happy that it
happened it's a sad tragic story
but he was a wanted fugitive who had a
gun and jumped in his car
the point is as i've described it the
people of minnesota
the officers and of portland are
standing inside a burning building
yeah we've warned them repeatedly to get
out
and in response to a giant beam smacking
one of the cops in the head
they go well we'll stand in the kitchen
instead of the living room it's like
maybe just
get out dude i've got a lot of messages
from cops who have said
they were they're they're the cops that
i refer to as the good cops who got out
when they saw how bad it was getting
and these are the cops who want to save
a little kid from getting kidnapped
these are the cops who want to stop the
drug dealers from destroying our
neighborhoods
these are the cops who want to make sure
that crime isn't skyrocketing in new
york city
but they can't do it anymore they're
getting targeted they're getting
arrested
so they're quitting and even in the
military there's similar similar things
happening with i saw your face uh
michael and i agree with you because if
we look at police if we look at policing
the last few months what have they been
doing they've been arresting
religious pastors they have been
arresting private businesses they have
been enforcing
unconstitutional illegal decrees of
politicians
and destroying people's livelihoods
while protecting the billionaire class
the nypd the florida police department
prosecutors judges the fbi intelligence
agencies
all looked the other way for 30 years
when it came to children being hurt in
the most unspeakable ways with a mr
epstein
so so so there's a lot of you know
discontent to bring up there
especially with what's happening in
canada right now where there was a
horrible video of a pastor being
arrested in front of his children
uh maxine bernay was just arrested for
hosting a political rally
right now the police in canada are
absolutely out of control and and i do
believe we need to strike a balance but
we need to have an honest conversation
that's not just one-sided on the issue
they've been there been a lot of
problems with cops for a very very long
time
but let's just keep in mind the stuff
we're seeing over the past year and into
now
a lot of the cops you'd probably like
have left i i was looking at my phone
because a cop
messaged me and he said because of your
work i'm quitting the force and i'm
mailing you my badge and i'm going to
private security
and i wanted to give him a shout out
which maybe i'll look for it later but
it's very kind of moving that uh i
even for one person that he's like okay
i i at the very least even if you're
gonna stay in the force
acknowledge what it is that you're doing
like i can even wrap my head around okay
i'm violating the constitution and i'm
disarming people but it's for
greater good fine like i could wrap my
head around that i i told this story
before when
when i went and was getting my first gun
the gun shop in jersey said they had a
big problem where a woman
so if you live in the south jersey area
you're
10 minutes from philadelphia you cross
the bridge you're in philadelphia
in pennsylvania you're allowed to bear
arms like very really great
good laws not perfect well a woman was
armed legally and she was going to
atlantic city
didn't look at the laws of new jersey
she made that mistake cop actually
arrested her
on a felony charge it's like why would
the cop do that why wouldn't the cops
say ma'am
you are not allowed to have this weapon
here in new jersey i'm going to escort
you back to the bridge you made a
mistake i understand please leave
take your gun home to where it's legal
for you to keep come back to my state
without that weapon
instead he's just like oh boy i got one
you're going to prison lady
i'm thinking about what you said about
abolish the police i'm wondering and
correct me if i'm wrong
if what you're what you're really saying
which so what you're saying is
got one out did you see i did i did i
saw i loved every minute hi kathy newman
jordan peterson himself
shout out to kathy but that you're
suggesting that police
boycott the department or strike on the
department if it's corrupt
yes not abolish the entire
system so it's a little bit more nuanced
but that is that is
just the point the other thing i'm
saying is
if the police force is becoming more and
more corrupt and some would argue
especially black lives matter and antifa
and even
and caps anarchists on the right any of
any capacity that they've been corrupt
for a very very long time notably
michael
i don't like that word corrupt here
because i think they're not being
dishonest
i think they're just being forced
through politics to do things in a
certain way
so so i'll put it this way if the police
are no longer serving the interests of
the public let's do that yeah
then why would i want to fund
something that causes harm to good
people if you're a cop
and you want a better society to be a
hero to help
then you need to reconcile one very
important circumstance
black lives matter and antifa have been
smashing up buildings and destroying
setting fires and these people are not
going to jail but
if i choose to keep and bear arms in
some ridiculous
twisted rule come if it comes into play
the cops will arrest me for that so if
you look at chicago for example and
mandatory minimums often
right so it's not like you're going to
get off that it's like it was your first
time with innocent mistakes like that
judge has to sentence you often
yep so this is the law so the cops need
to understand
even if i've had cops messaging me
saying look we just arrest lawbreakers
it's the it's the da's you're mad at and
i said no
if you personally know this and you do
because you're emailing me and you watch
the show
that the district attorneys you are go
if you know
that if you arrest one antifa and one
conservative
and send them both the da and the da
laughs and sends the antifa on his way
and then welcomes the conservative into
prison for bearing arms
you are the one delivering people to
prison
and you can and the officers can make
the choice to say
like i said with the new jersey lady
look lady ma'am you got a good cop right
here
i'm going to escort you back to the
bridge it's a 10-minute drive
you're going to go home you're going to
leave that gun otherwise some other
state trooper is going to lock you up
and i don't want to see that happen no
he didn't
he just said ma'am you're under arrest
the story was he pulls her over
and she did the right thing officer i am
armed i just we just
just want to let you know and he goes
right away man please step out of the
vehicle it's she gets up put your hands
behind your back
is something wrong ma'am quiet hands
behind your back arrest her you're under
arrest it's illegal it's a felony to
carry that weapon in new jersey
that's it and she freaks out she's
panicking some middle-aged women gonna
going to go to the casino and have a
good time
broke no laws was legally bearing i
should say constitutionally bearing her
arm
but in new jersey they say it's
statutorily illegal and the cop had
no problem sending a middle-aged woman
into the prison system fortunately
it was traumatic the nra apparently got
involved
and then made a big stink and the d.a
dropped the charges and told her not to
do it again
but they don't do that for people in the
inner city chicago for young black men
who want to protect themselves because
there's gang violence i got no sympathy
for somebody who wants to join gang
violence what about the old black ladies
who are going to be left in new york
city when everyone moves out and who are
in the projects who can't afford to move
absolutely lauren chen who you guys had
on who i adore
uh you know sometimes someone just says
one sentence that's kind of just light
bulbs you and
just rattles you from she's crazy she's
the best she was on my show was one of
hers i remember and she was having an
issue in canada because her dad had
cancer yes
and for like a year he couldn't even get
like a scan it was something absolutely
crazy
and she just goes why am i funding my
own oppression
and i was like holy like you like learn
you like nailed it and it's the kind of
thing where it's just like
yeah why am i paying these high taxes in
these cities
so the cops can leave me unsafe in my
own home
where i can't have a gun to protect
myself which is my god-given
constitutional right and none of your
business
right that's it i mean while you guys
are ginning up as much
unrest and burn it all down as possible
at the same time so so
my my issue is i'm in new jersey
i had a cop actually tell me to go buy a
gun because someone tried breaking in
and then i looked up the law and they're
like if the guy did break in
and you did shoot him you go to prison
yeah welcome yeah
and i'm like what he broke into my house
though and look we should have left
like where am i supposed to go it's my
house it's a big house like am i no no
this is back in jersey
small house okay yeah small oh it was
all okay sizes
but am i supposed to just go jump my
fence in my backyard and go stand in the
middle of the street
in my underwear you're supposed to die
and be a statistic
and then they could say look we're
fighting gun violence is an all-time
high we need more cops
right that's what lori lifefoot is doing
right now her emails were also
leaked recently and people are finding
out the true picture of who she really
was
but places like chicago and new york
city have absolutely atrocious
self-defense laws where even
if you get attacked first you defend
yourself you cause any mark or harm to
the perpetrator you go to jail no matter
what the situation no matter what the
circumstance and these officers don't
care
let me tell you about what i think one
of the biggest problems is sure
i will always lay the blame at the feet
of the perpetrator if a woman is wearing
you know she's scantily clad clothing
and walks through an alley
and someone attacks her she wasn't
asking for it the perpetrator the
criminal is this
is who should be punished who should be
blamed etc
but there is personal responsibility
involved you need to be aware of your
own surroundings you need to take some
responsibility so i don't think it's a
one-for-one like
when the left says oh people should be
allowed to be drunkenly wandering around
like i'm not going to go to an atm at
three in the morning all right so i'll
blame that the gun control left
and many of these democrats in these big
cities who who push for these things
and now i'm going to lay some blame at
the feet of conservatives who refuse to
fight back
we had the story saint louis gun waving
couple plead guilty to misdemeanor
charges
part of their plea is that they will be
giving up their weapons
they say mark and patricia mccloskey who
waved guns at protesters last year who
marched past their home
pled pleaded guilty thursday to
misdemeanors and agreed to give
up their weapons mark mccloskey will pay
a 750
fighter for pleading guilty to fourth
degree assault a class c misdemeanor
patricia 62 must pay a 2 000 fine after
pleading guilty to second
second degree harassment a class a
misdemeanor mark mccloskey could have
faced
15 days in jail patricia could have
spent up to a year behind bars neither
will face jail time
do not vote for these people isn't the
guy running for officers
senate and he just tweeted don't worry i
have more guns to protect my family
where that came from
do not do not vote for this man he is a
spineless coward
i wouldn't wait wait why is he spineless
when the cops came to take his guns away
he took a picture of him from behind and
said i don't want anyone to think bad of
these cops who are confiscating
oh i didn't know that all right oh holy
crap he's
dropping to his knees scared of the
state coming for him
giving up his weapons but i have more i
don't care dude get out of here
should have fought the legal battle come
on you can't advise someone to be a
martyr
would you i would not feel comfortable
taking on the state when there's this
whole
public frothing at the mouth mob and i'm
being made to political victim i'd do it
maybe you would but i don't think he's a
coward for being like i got a family
they've got me dead to rights because
they can write the law whatever they
want and
it's going to cost me millions of
dollars and they're the the government
can tax me to pay for them i i can't
i think i think his comments are
interesting and i think i think they
provide us context here he said quote on
his twitter account i'm bringing this
from his account
quote let me be clear i am not
surrendering any of my firearms i will
continue to be one of the strongest
advocates for the second amendment
and around the country the two weapons
that were seized from me were evidence
in a criminal case per the state
of uh m.o they are to be incinerated
so this is what this what yeah no i
don't make any sense
incinerating his weapon but he gets to
have something's evidence you return it
to the person or you keep it
possibly i guess this was a part of
their plea deal but why would they do
it's like it's like a circus it's like
they're doing this to entertain the
masses
they're like look what we did like this
when the cops came
they took a photo of the cops taking
their guns but from behind and said we
don't want to reveal the identities of
the officers because we don't want
people coming after whatever and i was
like
that's pathetic the cops could have said
no
the cops could have said we do not agree
with this and we will not enforce
unjust laws these these black lives
matter individuals
broke onto private property and
we even saw was it the ag of missouri
say that
they may as well been in their living
room it was a private lot it was it was
a private property the whole block was
privately owned
they could have defended themselves now
don't get me wrong i think them coming
out
and her like waving the gun was was very
dumb i'm not a fan of that either
but they could have been very scared we
don't know what that's like she didn't
have good trigger uh discipline at all
as well and she was literally
having her finger on the trigger
pointing the gun out of her husband's
head well and there was also
there was also they said the firing pin
was reversed and the gun was inoperable
the uh there's two guns right there that
was the
the ar 15 and what looked like a
revolver now
no no it wasn't a revolver um i don't
know i don't remember what it was but
did
it was a small handgun they claimed that
the firing pin was reversed and the gun
was inoperable
when it was when it was brought into the
like the to the da for evidence
they dis they disassembled and
reassembled it and then said oh it works
so a lot of people were coming out and
saying the state altered the evidence to
claim it was a functioning device
when the mccloskey said they had used it
in a criminal trial before
as evidence and so the firing pin was
reversed maybe they're lying
maybe they went inside and immediately
took it apart and did it i'm not going
to accuse them of that and i don't think
the citizen state has
any evidence they did that they just
claimed that well upon taking it apart
and putting it back together we found it
was functional
these people should have absolutely said
no
they should have said i will see you in
court if no one will stand up to the
system the system will always win
always i i just i completely disagree
with you
i think when you don't know someone's
personal circumstances it's really easy
to tell them
fight but this is the state i'm sorry i
think at a certain point some people
like discretion is a better form of
valor
and i would love me of all people for
f's sake
would love it if more people defied the
state and stood up to it but at a
certain point you're like okay
look at duncan lemp uh what happened
with him like they shot it killed him
at three in the morning through the
window and they dragged his pregnant
girlfriend through the broken glass and
blighted her up yeah
so you're telling me that it's not that
it's impossible
that the next time uh that they're gonna
make sure antifa goes by his house and
the cops are just
gonna take 9-1-1 put it on uh take the
phone off the hook and let nature take
its course
what do you mean meaning like this kind
of things happen all the time when
someone is an enemy to the state they
look the other way
and make sure that person gets taken
care of yeah so i mean when you're
saying like you should fight the state
you ask them to really take their life
into their own hands
now i can understand how someone would
do that but it's also really easy to
choose to understand someone would want
another
do you know what would happen if right
now in chicago
every single person facing trial demand
facing a
crim indictment or a criminal charge
asked for a jury trial
they would get uh charged with higher
charges
not true if in chicago every single
person awaiting uh
a an arraignment or whatever charge of
the crime said jury trial they would all
instantly be dismissed chicago
you think they don't understand that
explain it because the city doesn't have
the capability to handle that many
trials at once
so wait wait wait okay here's the two i
i don't agree with you
because what happens is when places
don't have resources they're just going
to keep you in jail longer
i know perhaps who have been in jail for
so long because of the coveted
regulations
and even covid has stopped the court
proceedings and what they did is just
keep people in jail longer so
i'll tell you this i got to ask you
you're saying that if everyone who's
arrested right now in chicago said i
demand a jury trial
the chicago legal systems you'll be like
we can't do this you're all going home
uh most of them probably would be
dismissed yes so
when uh i ended up getting charged with
i think a class c misdemeanor my brother
got a class a
they threw a the worst or the easiest uh
actually i don't i don't know if
a is the worst i think it was i think it
was a b okay i was facing 30 days my
brother was facing
uh six months oh wow and the
uh it was like six months of going to
trial because
long story short some security guards at
a mall falsely accused us and when they
realized that
they got the wrong guys in a shoplifting
uh they thought someone was shoplifting
they just lied to the cops the cops just
said whatever you say and arrested us
and charged us with like
assault and disorderly conduct they said
they will give us the maximum penalty
they said you will plead guilty and you
will take what we give you
and at first what happened was my
brother fearing six months
said i'll just plead guilty what what
will you have me doing said we're gonna
give you community service
and then i said 30 days i'll go to trial
this will this will be fun
when the prosecutor heard that i said i
wanted to go to trial
over a slap on the wrist they would give
me community service she
audibly screamed in the courtroom
shocked
what and then the judge had to tell her
to chill out
our lawyer walks back over to us and he
and and my brother is like
why is she yelling what happened well
when when she found out that you
he's like to me are being charged with
like a slap on the wrist level crime
wanted a jury trial
do you understand how much work that is
for them so she's she's kind of mad yeah
my brother goes
effort i'm going to i want to trial now
too and he goes
you're sure he goes trial and he goes
okay he walks back over and we see him
go up to the
to the prosecution of the judge and we
hear her scream again
and the judge starts saying calm down
and then they talk for a little bit
the our lawyer walks back over to us and
says the judge wants to see you in his
chambers and the judge said
what is going on and we said america
here's what happened and he goes
here's what's going to happen i don't
want to hear any lawsuits i want this
all to go away
the charges are being dismissed you're
free to go is that it
and we were like yes you're on he goes
have a nice day we asked the lawyer what
happened
and the judge when he found out that my
brother changed his mind and wanted a
jury trial
on a slap on the wrist charge court it
was it was a court
get court supervision and and community
service nothing right
when the judge heard that and he said to
the lawyer
why are your clients now trying to get a
trial out of this it's five o'clock
we want to go home and he went um your
honor
because they're innocent yeah and he
went oh
huh oh case dismissed uh in my chambers
and then he got up and walked in
the problem is too many people just say
well
because they're advised community public
defender we were told to by our lawyer
he said guys this is what's going to
happen you're going to get community
service
it's all going to be over you're going
to go home and play video games
and you don't even got to do anything
get one of your your dad's a firefighter
ask him to sign the papers
you're done here's something and i said
no
i want a jury to hear what happened when
they accused me of shoplifting
beat the crap out of me and my brother
when we did nothing wrong and i'm going
to stand up there with conviction and
say
i refuse to be beaten down by lying
security guards who use the state
because they
screwed up and we won because of it too
many people
are just scared i would gladly i know it
was just 30 days they could have been
facing a felony
but i would gladly have families and she
actually pointed a gun at people
and and she'll never like isn't that
brand new that's just me dude but i'm
talking i'm hot they're going to make
sure that jury is going to be filled
with people who saw her brandishing that
weapon let me just make
i'll go ahead well i'm very happy you
brought up duncan lamp but in missouri
the attorney general was one of the
attorney general's influence and
sponsored by george soros
she had a proverbial hard-on for these
people
uh the police officers at first said
we're not going to listen
to the d.a uh yeah yeah the the d.a
in missouri uh was specifically going
after them police officers at first
said that they wouldn't comply but then
officially they they complied later on
uh through a little bit of protest so
that's important uh context here as well
sorry go ahead and can i give people
some
some legal background yeah speaking
hypothetically because i'm not a lawyer
and i'm positioned to discuss this
in a legal context but hypothetically
it's a fairy tale
if you happen to be on a grand jury
here's how grand juries work right it's
going to be like 25 people
they're going to bring you the d.a is
going to bring you some evidence
and that evidence is not there to get a
conviction all that evidence has to do
is to say in the eyes of the grand jury
there is enough evidence here to pursue
charges meaning it's not nothing it's
something
and and the the joke is that any good da
can get you to indict a ham sandwich
this is basically a formality maybe the
founding fathers era whatever
that said most people hypothetically
are tend to be in in want of a leader
like they're in that
room they don't know what's going on
they want to do the right thing they
don't know what that is the only
guidance they're getting is from
that uh junior d.a so they're gonna come
in and there's gonna cop
hypothetically and say oh we found this
leafy substance in this guy's house and
now
this 18 year old kid is going to be
thrown in jail possibly with rapists and
murderers
his entire life is ambiguous up until he
gets charged or not
if you are in that grand jury and you
say hey guys there's nothing
holding us to return what they call a
true bill which means he's indicted
we can just vote no and ignore the
evidence and
and someone could say listen you we're
here we have a responsibility
do you really want to ruin this kid's
life
because he had a lot of weed in his
house and was probably selling it just
think about everyone you know who's ever
done weed
do you think they should go to jail
think about what jail means it's not
like i can't go to my job it's like i'm
locked in a little room
with people that i know kill children
rape women repeatedly and what will
happen
hypothetically speaking is that those
jurors now they've been given permission
to do the right thing be like why am i
ruining this kid's life this i know
people smoke weed i don't i don't think
they should go to jail maybe they
shouldn't be doing the right thing
and that da will come back and say how
did you guys say
and they'll say all charge been dropped
and they will not be able to ask you why
and they're just going to be very very
confused because this hasn't happened
but you will have been a position to
save some kid's life
and he will never know who did it or why
but he'll be very grateful
and you can go to sleep that you made
the world a better place
there's also jury nullification that is
jury notification well yeah so but you
could be on an actual criminal
proceeding right so
in the grand jury yes if you are
actually sitting on a jury
and they say this guy uh you know had
weed or something and you don't think
they should be in prison for it you can
say not guilty
and they're like but the evidence it's
like the cops found it they presented it
he admitted it was his yeah not guilty
i strongly i strongly recommend people
look into jury nullification and
whenever you get a jury notice
don't see it as something negative see
it as an opportunity to provide
services to the community that could
actually help people and i just want to
make a quick correction
the missouri attorney general actually
filed to dismiss the charges
but it was prosecutor kim gardner that
was the one that was strongly going on
thank you
and and i will also add the governor
said he wanted to pardon
the gun-toting couple so what happened
to a trial and that
would pardon them he announced that he
would pardon and they should have
dropped
charges every step of the way and you
know what this is the
look i i hear what you're saying but if
the leaders we have are the ones willing
to to to drop the knee to the enemy
combatants these aren't leaders these
are just two old people
sure no they're not vendors then there's
there's there's no
cohesive um resistance there is cohesive
cohesive resistance doesn't have to be
unanimous
i i think i tim i just think it's really
really easy for us to sit here and tell
people we've never met what do people
tell you
what you should be doing all the time
i'm sure you don't like it
i mean in what context like online
they're like oh your show should be like
this your show should be like that so on
and so forth it's like
you don't know me like keep thank you
for your opinion so we don't know this
couple we don't know maybe she's got
some kind of illness i don't know
yeah perhaps i'm just like i said maybe
a little bit more hot-headed like
like i mentioned it could be my soviet
blood so my soviet dna is like once the
state has gotten you in the eye of
sauron
do whatever you can to get out of the
israel get out fully
my family fled communism in poland
because it was getting too crazy
right that i understand that i
understand that the issue i take here is
that
yeah i think i i i'll start interrupting
you but it sounds like you're saying the
system works and just because it worked
for you guys
i don't know that it's at all a
guarantee that's gonna work for these
two so when you're a 63 year old woman
to go to jail the system didn't work for
us but you got off
it was it was clear the only reason we
did was because the system didn't want
to deal with two jury trials
sure but the point is that's how broken
it was the point is
you you managed to get the result that
you wanted here's here's the issue i
take with this
for the most part certainly i understand
there are circumstances where you you uh
a strategic retreat makes sense yeah it
would be dumb if you're like i'm by
myself and there's 500 people in front
of me but i'm charging it anyway
that's really dumb they had the support
of the right they had the support of the
governor they're the
support of the state ag i didn't think
they could have won this
they could have been convicted and then
he the governor could have made a
statement saying i refuse to allow this
in my state
unconditional pardon he could have done
it for whatever reason they had no faith
so they decided just to get out with
what they could
to give their weapons up the entire the
you know i would not put my
freedom in the hands of a governor no
matter what he said publicly at any time
because that word is worth nothing to me
and he would throw me on the bus in two
seconds it would help his re-election
yeah probably and i think therein lies a
big part of the problem and the
frustration i have is that
the left absolutely will do everything
in their power to win
kamala harris will publicly solicit
donations to get criminals and rioters
out of prison
and the right can't even rely on their
own to support them
correct yeah it's frustrating i wanted
to point out i think maybe there is a
time and a place to bend the knee
when the villain's like on your knee and
then you go down on your knee and he
walks up to you and you're like
yeah you do like a giant uppercut one of
the things i'm talking about perhaps in
my next book the white pill which is a
lot about the soviet union
is i don't think people in this country
i know people in this country
and i have no doubt luke and you and you
you all back me up
are completely oblivious to what the
state can do to people to get them to
bend the knee
it's not like good cop why are you why
are you making that you say we're
oblivious to it i think a lot of
americans are oblivious to it oh you're
saying not us
not us not the people in this room but
i'm saying a lot of americans like
like i had a when castro died right
there's all these laudatory
um obituaries about him and i'm like you
know in a way it's kind of good
that you guys have no idea what this is
like that you think like oh he's
basically like a liberal democrat or
like a
trump figure like you have no clue and i
want a world in a sense where people
like
i kind of get that hypothetically but i
can't imagine this being reality so i
can appreciate that
so the things that the soviets did to
break these people
they haven't come over here yet but one
of the things they always do like
they'll arrest people on a friday night
and they want them to squeal they're in
jail till monday
and it's like i'll need to break one of
you and the offer is good for that one
person so who's it gonna be
monday morning they're they're banging
that door and you can't blame them yeah
my favorite is seeing people wear czech
guevara shirts
and and understanding that history and
context and uh
you're absolutely right i had family
members that were tortured by the
government of course
uh under a communist regime and
when you wake up to that reality when
you speak to your family when you hear
the stories
when you know so much knowledge is
passed on to you which which
barely happens the united states had it
too good for too long
and i think now we're finally dealing
with a lot of the larger ramifications
of what happens when
when things are too good you know the
cia didn't know how to torture people at
gitmo so they had to use kgb manuals
they we didn't have any background yes
interesting look this up double check
that maybe i'm talking on my butt but
just double check me but i'm 99 sure
that's okay
i suppose the issue i have right now is
that there's uh
i got to say one more thing tim don't
you think it's not maybe it's not
literal torture
it's not literal torture but if you're
like a senior citizen close to it and
you're in prison over a weekend
that's gonna really do a huge number on
you psychologically come on i mean i was
in jail for a few days for for doing
journalism and reporting and
it takes a toll on you you definitely
don't want to be in there and then you
to know your wife is
somewhere in this building separated
from you and you like i hope she's okay
and you know how she is and she doesn't
even know how to hold a gun correctly
that's tim that's scary and trauma makes
people make
you know very conflict diverse decisions
i guess uh i think the larger lesson
here i'm hot-headed yeah
i think the larger i can explain it i've
been and i've been in conflict
situations where my life was at risk and
i've returned to those situations
and perhaps it's because i don't have
children maybe sure
uh when i was in brazil i went to
the was it called shiodado do policia
the uh city of police the police city
it's like their big compound
and we had plainclothes cops basically
walk up to us
take us in take our phones shut them off
they brought us into this back area into
this closed no window
with the couch yeah and i said the first
thing i did as soon as they started
taking us
before they took our phones because i
texted i was when i was advice like
we're being taken by brazilian secret
police or something undercovers
and i don't know where they're bringing
us but just so you know here we are
yeah then they took our phones shut them
off they brought us in this back room
and i started laughing i was like so
this is where we get beaten up and
tortured
and they held us there started
interrogating us and then after about
like a half an hour someone ran
in you know panicked in portuguese and
they brought us back out and apologized
so you know experiencing that and then
uh not the end of the world but
certainly being brought through this
complex and then being brought
into this back room not knowing what to
expect or where they were bringing us
and also uh i i've also written vehicles
with
i don't know how to describe individuals
like violent extremists and
revolutionaries armed with guns
i was in charlottesville i i mean i know
you're talking about this this stuff
gets scary really
quick but i i returned to those places
not the same specific ones
that that have actually spoken out
against but like experiencing venezuela
where i was accused of being a spy and
forced to flee the country
and then having the venezuelan uh
someone hack my friends
facebook to send me fake messages to get
me to make phone calls then to just go
back into thailand
you know i understand like i'm not gonna
return to venezuela i can't sure
i can't go to thailand but i would go
initially constantly facing that danger
i'm well aware of what it means to stand
up and fight and i'm well aware that uh
you must plant uh the trees whose shade
you know you'll never sit beneath if you
want a society to grow great
that means for me personally strategy is
involved right so when it comes to
censorship on youtube one of the biggest
criticisms we get is tim why won't you
just say it
well i'm not going to get the whole show
banned right and and and our opportunity
to speak the truth
by saying one thing but that's why we're
building a website we ought to be
strategic about it so i will i will
contend
i don't know everything about the
mccloskey situation and perhaps a
strategic retreat made sense i'll give
one a scenario where it would make
perfect sense to everybody
which is what if they have a kid who's
like mom i really don't need you to be
the face of the gun rights movement
can we just make this go away and i want
to have a normal family i don't want to
be famous
that is a perfectly good reason to be
like yeah what you know what i'm not
going to fight this
i disagree but the father's running to
be a senator sure that's
who knows but i'm saying like that would
be one scenario maybe it's not literally
them where i could be like you know what
i'm not going to do this
no i don't know wife is like i don't
have the fortitude i
i've uh uh and she could have
individually
sure taken a deal um i i just grew up
constantly frustrated at the lack of
unity solidarity how's that for a word
when i would see
my friends constantly complain about how
they work for a restaurant it's unfair
they're not getting paid enough
and i'd say so if you all agree why
don't you all just
stop working and they're like oh no i
have to and i'm like there's five of you
you could literally just walk out the
front door and stand there and say we're
not going to walk back in the building
unless we get another dollar an hour
and they'd say yes please get back to
work well i can't do that
i'm like well then you're not going to
get your dollar an hour like what do you
mean if people
just stood up for themselves if everyone
finally just agreed we'd be done with it
if people had principal value strength
courage
and were willing to make the sacrifices
to defend
freedom individual liberties we would
have never have had it at risk in the
first place
it's coordination too you need all these
values along with
like some sort of sort of sociological
coordination because if you do it one by
one you just
whack them all it's true yeah it's true
and that's the thing if everyone in
chicago demanded a jury trial what i bet
would happen and i think if you thought
about the story you would think this
happened too
they would take a very few case up front
make real examples out of them
uh charge them with everything that they
could and then ask everyone else you
sure you want the jury trial
and if they said yep i i i think a lot
of those people would break and i
wouldn't blame them for one bit
the point is for everyone to stand up
and say i demand a jury trial would be
them
standing strong assuming the people
don't break they win
but but i i don't see any scenario where
an entire population acts in concert
as as pressure increases it's just i i i
agree i agree
the problem is the they don't work
together sure
if this the system cannot maintain that
many jury trials
barely a fraction of them but that's why
you have public education so that these
kids are taught
from kindergarten before they can really
walk and read
that the authorities are genuinely good
people
who maybe they get it wrong sometimes
maybe not always smart they're a little
ignorant sometimes
but they do want what's best for
everyone that you have to punish some
people to save everybody else
they're the good guys so it's very hard
to realize
as an adult when this has been your
entire context that you are
means to an end for these people in law
enforcement that they have certain
numbers and quotas they want to meet
that they get off on getting those
convictions or else this wouldn't be
their job because how could you sleep at
night
if you're putting away people you even
suspect are innocent so yeah like
it's it's a it's much more malevolent
and what they were doing to you and your
brother
was you and your lawyer who you had was
another version of good cop bad cop
because then you have the lady screaming
and your lawyer could be like hey i'm a
good guy
i'm just going to get your community
service how can you lose look at this
crazy lunatic you don't want to deal
with bad cop
i'm a good gupp i'm your buddy and
you're like most people be like hey i
want to listen to good cop i'm going to
take this deal
you know i think i was just
i refuse i i think that's extremely
commendable
you know i but in some regards but like
i've been to north korea
you know what i mean i know some and
this is obviously not a north korean
situation
it's very i i'm very reticent to
encourage people to take risks without
knowing their situation
that said i 1 000 in defiance of
mathematics agree with you
that if everyone unanimously or a large
portion of population stood up and said
we're going no further that's going to
be really really hard for them to do
anything about
and it's only i think actually a few
percentage points of a population i
agree
uh for the revolutionary war exactly it
was uh supported by
less than the majority but their i think
the largest faction of people in the
revolution was leave me alone
yes yes with most elections right
absolutely
so if uh right now there was just
general
mass non-compliance or a general strike
among conservatives maybe general
strikes the wrong words because
non-compliance is probably better
keep working support yourself grow your
own food hunt your own food
shop shop locally organically and just
stop using the major corporations they'd
be in panic in two seconds
how you coordinate that's it's i think a
lot about how you could make an internet
video and be like
everyone i'm just saying hypothetically
you could coordinate people like
withdraw their bank account on the same
day at the same time
and just basically collapse the house of
cards but this is what's kind of
happening with like your show and like
my book
and our sponsors is that people have an
opportunity to put their money where
their mouth is and to create this
parallel economy
and parallel culture and they're doing
it peacefully
and they're doing it through freedom and
it's something where this is with the
beauty of free enterprise
literally everybody wins the sponsor
sells their product and they have
and they're also supporting people they
like that person gets to do his book or
his show
as an audience member i'm getting a
product i wanted anyway and part of this
money is going to make sure something i
enjoy stays in perpetuity
it's it's all wins all around i'm
short-term pessimistic long-term
optimism yes
that's my point too and the reason i
think so is looking at the website we're
launching
uh teamcast.com and the things that
we're building i'm 100
confident we're going to succeed yes 100
and that means if there is a new
expansion in media which i firmly
believe will be
one of the biggest media companies in 10
20 years
and news and all that stuff then uh what
does that feature look like
it looks like a large amount hundreds of
millions of people around the world will
be getting real news
and we'll have uh the content we produce
we rooted in individual liberties and
freedom and personal responsibility this
is what i talk about all the time people
like how you optimistic are you just
blowing smoke on my butt i go
look at don lemon look at the white
house press corps are you look at the
the
look at the staff at harvard law you're
telling me these people are smarter more
cur
educated and more coordinated and have
more power than stalin
than hitler but you have to laugh but we
beat them
this is who you're up against now and
you think you're going to lose it's the
banks
i think that it forces the banks
capitalism is in
incredibly symbiotic but when you
install a banking system in the middle
that's
that's profiting and causing interest
basically an induced slave labor on us
that's the problem if we could remove
the banks and each of us hold our own
crypt
you know with your own crypto you're
basically your own bank there's no more
banks i'm going to follow
luke's advice what luke would say is we
need to fund the fed
we need to increase the fed's powers
over currency
to make sure we're all fair right luke
protest give all of your money
and make it meaningless and then we have
monopoly money everywhere no i'm just
kidding
it's basically this point uh i mean we
basically already have monopoly money
with how much they're printing it
uh but i i think also another aspect
here that we have to entertain is that
the state is becoming more and more
desperate
yes we're seeing more and more draconian
measures being implemented we're seeing
a lot of fbi infiltration organizing
setting up events that they later take
credit for
uh bringing down we have this latest
revelation about the capital
riots where a lot of the people are not
being charged because they were either
cooperating or
helped organized planned and carried out
the events that they're no longer being
held responsible for
this as the biden administration
literally announces their new war on
terror
which is a domestic war on people who
don't like the government militias
and their buzz word of the day white
supremacy which could mean anything
because that word has been bastardized
did you see the ap is refusing to report
on some uh crimes
no so the ap a news organization as a
new organization organization
my job is to provide information to the
populist ostensibly is what they always
say
free press free from democracy well the
associated press which is
extremely big uh uh very respected news
organization they had an article this
week
where they said we are no longer going
to report on the names or appear
or show mug shots if someone is arrested
for a crime that's not that big a deal
because we don't want this to like haunt
them throughout the rest of their life
that they're google
their life words okay so wait you do a
crappy little crime
shoplifting whatever the ap will cover
the story but they won't mention your
name or mugshot
but i tweeted some rap lyrics in high
school
and now i got this job as an athlete
well let's drive you to suicide
so it's very clear what they regard as a
real threat and a real crime and
what they don't well i there's good news
there
is a political party that's going to
find us a way out
i love you so much i love doing the show
i love this show what's going on with
the libertarian party in new hampshire
lydia has the documents yes okay so
this is i i am going to give a garbled
version of this because this is like
playing telephone but i'm very very glad
i get to do this because then everyone
could be like okay he's talking out of
his butt
let me double check and when they look
it up they'll be like no this is right
so dave smith who's this aspiring
comedian who guys have had on the show
he's great amazing he is a big member of
the libertarian party
and his followers are something called
the mises caucus which is named after
this very failed think tank the music
institute
so they're the more radical of the
libertarians right
so he's brought a lot of energy to the
libertarian party which has historically
and correctly been regarded as a joke
and state by state they've had these
conventions and they've been electing
their slates for delegates whatever the
position is
and the meecox people have been running
the table because he's just bringing all
the energy
and it's all these kind of like lowest
status uh people have nothing to bring
to the table and then
this is their chance to be members of
the party they won in new hampshire
new hampshire of all the states this is
i completely uh
could be wrong in this one that's the
home of the free state project that's
where all the hardcore
libertarians move to and people can look
at the free state project it's a great
idea
i highly encourage people look it up
what happened was what was the woman's
name
gigi i sent you the the the woman who's
the head of the libertarian party of new
hampshire
unilaterally said jarvis jilletta jarvis
she was there she was their candidate
for governor
she she's i sent the letter please you
can read it where she basically said
everyone who was in the libertarian
party previously
is now not part of the libertarian party
i
am the libertarian party because i got
unanimously voted to be the chair
i'm going to pass a new series of bylaws
unilaterally no one vote on them
i am going to extend my term to four
years no one vote on this
and now this is the new lp and you guys
are not the lp
right wow so they are like well we have
all the bank accounts
and all the everything else she has
their twitter their twitter
i just that was hot i went full brooklyn
yeah it was hardcore two yoots
what is that what just happened twitter
did i just get possessed by smoking
okay she has their twitter and their
social media
and this was a huge drama it's like you
just stole the entire thing and you're
worried about this kind of like
alt-right thing you're acting like a
fuhrer
the libertarian national committee had a
meeting on youtube you could go look it
up a couple days ago
they voted and they basically endorsed
what she did they're like how they're
like look if you wanna like uh dissolve
one state party we have that in our like
constitutional bylaws which is
you have a meeting you call a motion
you're like all right three quarters of
what i think it is
this libertarian part of new hampshire
dissolves the nuclear option we're going
to reform it
she's like we didn't do that if you want
to do that let's have the vote they're
like nope
now the guy who's the head of
libertarian party john bishop henchmen i
think is his name he sent out a letter
which lydia has and he says anyone by
the way i should let you know as a
lawyer
this is great libertarianism uh anyone
who cast aspersions on my
integrity or can you please read it blah
blah blah
is setting themselves up for legal
action just so you're warned and people
like
wait you're the head of the libertarian
party very arguably a public figure
and you're threatening lawsuits against
fellow libertarians
but apparently i got a message from dave
that they completely lost everything's
getting handed over right now
yeah i'm seeing a lot of pushback
against the libertarian party on twitter
and the free state project
tweeted a couple days ago quote the free
state project was
explicitly founded as a result of the
continued failures of the libertarian
party
we're thrilled to see new hampshire be
growing increasingly libertarian
and very few free staters care what
party does it
uh so a lot of people are pushing back
and i'm seeing people burning t-shirts
i'm seeing some people
sell the t-shirts i am here to declare
let me finish this by point
following suit with what's her name
again i don't know levi jarvis
i am hereby declaring that i'm actually
the chairman of the libertarian party
that all these people who are claiming
to be otherwise are uh uh fraudulent i'm
kind of the libertarian party chairman
exile
and i expect all the party assets to be
returned to me
according to the new bylaws which i'm
writing which will be forthcoming
can i second that yes absolutely
look i got a couple questions the free
state project is that like where they're
trying to get all the people to come
there and like become residents and then
vote for freedom or something yes
and slowly go into positions in local
government
and they have elected a large number of
local representatives that passed a lot
of local laws
including ones where you could now
choose your tax dollars to go
to nonprofits that teach people how to
homeschool their children
so your taxes could effectively go
towards efforts that free children
and educate them through a community way
instead of a public schooling way
and new hampshire slowly and surely is
implementing a lot of different actions
a lot of different proposals and they're
getting them through which is absolutely
exciting
how are the taxes in new hampshire the
property is the lowest
it's one of the lowest tax places but
property taxes are a little
bit high but it's it's the place that
has it's the place that has some of the
highest gun ownership
and the least the highest yeah yeah and
then the least amount of murders
at least the amount of crime the the
place with the highest iq the most
amount of home school children
uh the place that has the most economic
opportunities and the most amount of
bitcoiners and
more bitcoin transactions than any other
state
because they have a list of all the
things that are awesome i mean this is
why i moved
to new hampshire and i'm going to be
going back there in just a few days to
be a part of pork festivals
the polish people yes you do you're
doing so well now it's like
there's actually a lot of polish people
in new hampshire let's go back to this
lady what's the url though
hold on let's pull up something let's go
back to this lady
she's trying to take over the party no
no she has taken over she's okay
declared herself to be the party
she's declared it she is the fear of the
libertarian party uh
is it because dave smith they don't like
or yeah because
they're saying dave smith is bringing
all these bigots and racists and all
these other cathedral terms
and that that's not what we're about so
oh my god i finished i forgot the best
part
she said and this is if you go to lp nh
their twitter
the libertarian part of new hampshire if
you want to join the libertarian party
new hampshire
you have to sign or say i don't remember
what their mechanism is a loyalty oath
that she wrote
what and she put it go to lpnh their
twitter
what is it just at lpnh yeah i believe
so
it's a big graphic interesting let me
see if i can uh
when do they post it uh within the last
week maybe the 12th
so michael is this just because they've
gotten woke is that a symptom
they've been woke and now they're being
this is what it is the libertarian party
is a mechanism for lowest status people
to have some modicum of respect and do
something with their lives
and now that they're being outnumbered
and the only thing that's of value to
them is being taken away
of course they're going to use every
trick at their disposal to maintain
their hold on this minuscule amount of
power now this is my
interpretation they of course have a
different perspective that we're keeping
libertarian parties safe from nazis
dave smith even those family or
holocaust survivors but that is kind of
the two sides of this issue yeah and
it's hilarious because i was watching
that youtube
of the uh executive channel meeting and
i go this must have been what the
communist party meetings were like in
the 30s
except everyone's on the spectrum yeah
so so dave smith tweeted the lpnh fiasco
has been resolved the attempted coup has
failed
this was not an lpmc versus lp thing
this was a few corrupt people versus all
of the decent honorable people of the
libertarian in the libertarian party
real spike cohen justin amash uh yeah
carrie what does this carry on harlow
carlos yes
and others displayed true integrity so i
wonder if they took down the loyalty of
things i couldn't find it
oh wow they might i look forward to the
other thing is they were threatening
legal action they're like okay
this has nothing to do with your
politics like no one vote on this you
can't just one lady say these then you
bylaws that makes no sense
right so if uh uh if i vote for um
dave smith will i get a press secretary
michael malus along with it
yeah so here's my here's what my deal
was okay if you go to malice or press
secretary.com
i said to myself the only way i would
sign on
to i would repress here during the
campaign not even presidency
i would say i would sign on as
communications director if i had
one bitcoin a month in the bank as
security
because if they came for me and they try
to completely cancel me and destroy me
and all these smear pieces
i have to know i'm not going to be
homeless that would be the greatest
thing we have seen in politics in my
lifetime and
this i promised people and i will i
and i will say this right now and i'll
affirm to it under oath
i would unleash such a season of poison
on social media that donald trump would
look like mother teresa
[Laughter]
i'm not kidding the amount of hatred and
contempt i have for political class
is so off the charts that i literally
can't even talk about it
because the show i would be on would be
cancelled i
everyone gets canceled now i would like
to see a michael mouse press secretary
very much
yeah he'll be very entertaining i want
to be part of the part of the cabinet
man let's roll
let's build free software
[Music]
i'm not into the the crazy stuff no
crack i'm you know no cocaine
have you tried crack negative okay i've
had friends who tried it not into
stimulants and
downers and uppers i just like
psychedelics drugs are bad okay
hey yeah sugar but what i want to see is
your quick wit when the journalists come
asking questions you know what i would
do i'll tell you exactly what i'll do
tell me what you do
uh the thing that is a real issue with
washington
is that everyone it's very incestuous
now in a way it's it sounds worse than
it is because if you're all like in like
a
upper middle upper class and you're all
swimming the same circles
of course the person who works for this
organization works is going to marry
someone who works for this university i
mean these are the circles you travel in
but to americans it looks much more
nefarious and i think in a sense it is
more affairs than people realize because
if your wife works for this charity
you're kind of going to be have a
different relationship to it you can't
help it this is your wife this is her
life's work right
but if you have that press secretary
constantly pointing out these
relationships
this is really going to upset them which
is a good in and of itself but it'll
also point out to americans
just how the system is us versus them at
it
george carlin it's a big club and you
ain't in it
so i think it's the same big club they
used to beat you over the head with yeah
so this is the kind of thing where i
think people will be very receptive
because it's one thing to be aggressive
like oh you're an idiot you're a fake
news it's not to be like
look you guys are all in this big kind
of high school thing
and that leaves the average guy out in
the streets and president smith is doing
something about it because he's much
more of a schlub
than he is one of you it would be
probably how he dresses it's a disaster
it's a complete embarrassment i don't
say it others do
i think the libertarian party uh for the
longest time
was i don't want to say controlled
opposition
but you look at joe jorgensen coming out
and saying and telling people what they
must do was
that was one of the funniest things
about she went to dershow it's a part of
the supreme court
wow yeah that's that's well she said it
is not enough to be
not racist we must be actively
anti-racist and i was like
sure is something seeing the libertarian
party telling me what i must do
the libertarian party in new hampshire
unfollowed me
as we're speaking it follows you when i
hit refresh it went away
oh but they took it back it said one
minute ago literally one minute ago they
pin tweet
we're back three exclamation points the
libertarian part in new hampshire is now
in control of our assets and data
we would like to sincerely thank those
on the lnc who came to our defense and
those who supported us
help us further our mission at and the
link is anarchist handbook.com
so if you want to help the libertarian
party make sure you buy the answer i
want this
book yeah let's talk about your book so
you just this is like top
of the charts uh number one best-selling
not was it fiction
non-fiction they did they erased all the
tweets no no you're right i'll look for
it so this
this is what happened and i have no uh
uh rational explanation
okay i did many of you guys know i was
just on jordan peterson's show uh not
that long ago we taped it a few months
ago it just dropped
i don't even mention this book in the
show at all so i just
how amazon works and can i get like five
minutes because this something i think
it's me edifying because this is an
example of how
the regular person can take on the
publishing houses and win
okay if you want and it's unfortunate
it's going to be through amazon but
right now they basically have monopoly
soon there's gonna be four or five
venues
how it works is you create your document
make sure you get a professional book
design and so on and so forth you upload
it to their create space site
they have to clear it and then once they
clear it it's on amazon to buy just like
any other book
the problem is when i sent them this
which is a collection people always ask
me and cause people ask better because
they're interesting
and i would get bored with it i'm like i
don't have time to answer a question
like you know what
there is no book that people can go to
to get the complete idea of all the
calls of black flag so i'm like i'm
going to put together this book
historical essays
so they'd email me back they'd be like
we have a problem with this essay when
did this person die i'm like michael
bacon and died in like the 1800s this is
public domain
we have a question with this one and in
between it's three or four days
so you're sitting there you don't know
how many days it's gonna happen then
they're like it's live so if there's no
you can't have a release date my next
book i'm gonna get it cleared ahead of
time
so that i can hit published on whatever
december first it drops
and no i didn't mention any of the shows
i did i didn't have a big push because i
didn't know when it was coming out
for a full day it was the number three
book on all of amazon
it was the top non-fiction book on all
of amazon number one was dr seuss
number two was some ladies novel number
three was me for it wasn't like a spike
because i did some show or someone
mentioned it
the fact that it's still so it was
beating obama it was beating hillary it
was beating
president trump it was beating oprah
everybody
and the only way this happened was
through fans
and word of mouth i still don't
understand how it happened because it's
asymptotic
it is much much harder to go from 20 to
10 than from 30 to 20.
you're getting steeper and steeper we
did it i'm delighted by the response
and this is a good example of how one
person with a motivated fan base
spreading the ideas of liberty as
opposed to libertarian party bro
i was on breitbart earl this week alex
marlow who's great he's got a book out
we're doing better sorry alex
he was reading a whole section of emma
goldman on breitbart
the fact that i could have people
talking about radical ideas
and people are hungry for radical ideas
is shows that there is a market for it
people love to talk about these concepts
but they're not usually allowed to in
corporate media
the lp wants none of it and that's why
they're a joke and that's why when i
take over it's going to be really funny
i think we were some of those fans you
were you guys pushed it it means a lot
were you still chairman though i i think
i'd be chairman in the chinese sense
okay god and the president so one of the
things we we had said right we keep
getting super chats
where people are like they'll say
something innocuous and then turn it
into a pitch for michael nolan's book
sure so they'll be like you know i can't
believe what they're doing with canceled
culture on social media
it's leaving me speechless much like
michael knows his book speechless
and uh whenever you know so we read them
and it is clever but i always say
uh you know so i've i've you know
chatted with michael a little bit and
he's just like oh man are they
they're they're still pushing that meme
and i was like it's fantastic i love it
yeah i want it i want everyone to buy
your book so it's the top of the charts
i want everyone to buy michael malus's
book
at the top of the charts i want everyone
to buy andy noe's on mass top of the
charts
all of them then when regular people go
to amazon to find a book what are they
going to get
the most influential subjects are going
to be written by smart people
challenging the establishment and here
i'm going to let you guys in a little
inside baseball i've not told anyone
this is the first time revealing this
i got a call from one of the major major
publishers there's only four or five of
them
and and this is an editor i knew and he
goes your book got flagged
because whenever you have these
independent books that do gangbusters
it's our job to be like how did this
happen and he's getting on a call with
me and i like the guy but i'm gonna tell
him
you guys are screwed there's nothing you
could do to fix your model
you're gonna go the way of warner
brothers atlantic records which back in
the day there are four or five record
labels
all the records are through them now you
guys still have a large proportion
just like abc cbs and nbcf of sitcoms
but in terms of channels there's not
only a cable
like dozens on youtube it's literally
infinite
you are never going to be in a position
to be
random house or st martins or simon
schuster the way you were
because i right now have demonstrated to
you
and i'm not magic that i could go there
and beat you at your own game and here's
the other thing
let's suppose they can run the table on
me if i sold this book to them on
january 1st
it would come out january 2023. what
happened was in february a friend of
mine marla
said look there hasn't been a book like
this the last one that was like this in
the 60s wasn't you that audiobook
and i said why don't you just do it from
scratch and it was out in may
so that turn around is something they
are not in a position to do
so this book is it's a collection of
essays correct by a bunch of famous
anarchists and you're going to read one
i am going to read one of the classic
essays shortly after we wrap up here in
the audiobook
and but but is is is there like a lot of
original
from you in this no this is so the whole
point of this is people always ask me if
anarchism is from an authority on the
subject haha
the slogan i have on the back is the
black flag comes in many colors
this has been a long historical
tradition that is swept under the rug
there's very many variants there's the
hardcore narco communists which in many
ways are predecessors to antifa
there's the contemporary and arc
capitalists which the left wings do not
consider anarchists at all but this just
shows
alternatives to government and critiques
of government from many different points
of view
let me ask you about the political
compass right people people like to say
that antifa is the left libertarian
quadrant
and that i would say libertarian left
certainly yeah right definitely not
libertarian right um
people like you just mentioned an arc of
communists for the precursor to
antifa sure i'm not i i don't believe
that those who would use force to impose
their will over others would be
classified as
libertarian or anarchist but there was
certainly the anarchists like the guy on
the cover lewis ling his essay he was
arrested by illinois uh for being
for making bombs and he's explicitly set
up for force
so their vision this was their argument
and i i
since we're on youtube i'm going to be i
have to make clear this is historical
stuff
there's nothing i'm endorsing people
doing it's not something i personally
believe in
but their argument because they came out
of a communist tradition which is not
marxist
so i would strongly all the people who
are libertarians who read this the one
essay they love the most
is by michael bacon from 1867. bakunin
was marx's big rival
for the international left and his essay
50 years for the soviet union
said this is what marxism is going to
mean in practice this is why it's a
nightmare a thousand times worse than
the czar you guys are crazy you guys are
evil this is not what we're about he
called it it's all in here
so they were for force in this sense
their argument was which again i don't
agree with
that because the police and the
government are
tools of the wealthy to exploit the
population and to keep
poor laborers starving and can't feed
their kids remember this before the
welfare state
it is our job to use weaponry as
self-defense
to have this revolution to have you guys
not keep bleeding us dry so so
in that regard perhaps i agree with you
that they were the precursor to antifa
which i view as an overtly authoritarian
left movement because they attack
regular people
correct so they would not be in favor of
that
any of the people in this book would not
be in favor of that right right so that
i guess that's my distinction the modern
version of the people who claim to be
left libertarian are anything but
and let me also uh defend these commies
from a lot of these
argo capitalists emma goldman who i love
was deported by woodrow wilson via j
edgar hoover
in the uh during the great war and sent
to russia
and she goes there because the argument
is when push comes to shove these people
are gonna be stalinists
she goes to russia she's looking around
she's like this is not where we're about
this is disaster
she goes to lenin's office yells at him
she goes
we're anarchists we're we are for free
speech before the maximum freedom of
individual what are you guys doing he
goes
free speech he told her her face free
speech is a bourgeois contrivance
at the very least you can't have it
during periods of revolution so go home
emma
her mentor karpotkin was under house
arrest you know in the soviet union
she left with her partner in crime
literally crime alexander berkman
they each wrote books denouncing this
and emma's was called my disillusionment
in russia
when she went to britain emma goldman
the heroin the left she's the you know
this is as left as it gets
she gave a speech she starts with a
standing ovation
she's like guys what's going on the
soviet union is a nightmare
this is exactly what we're opposed to
this is horrible from beginning to end
when she was done you could he you could
hear a pin drop because they weren't
hearing it
because they were more than happy that
this is going to be a big theme in my
next book
to have all these russians over there
let's have it be an experiment
listen if if it doesn't work who cares
it's the russians it's not affecting us
and if it works then we get to import it
so this was really cynical sick stuff
and when ayn rand uh who escaped the
soviet union was on donahue in 1979 i
tweet this all the time
donahue says to her how are you so harsh
against these people
how are you just condemnatory can't just
say you disagree why do you call them
some evil she goes
because i look at them because they
don't hesitate to sacrifice whole
nations
and more recently in our time venezuela
which you mentioned
how many people were like hell yeah hell
yeah hell yeah venezuela what's going on
there
and then later they weren't like what if
i i could i would
have i would be perfectly fine with them
being like you know what
just a goldman or berkman they're like i
thought this was going to be great
and look how it turned out i was wrong
and we really need to have salida with
people venezuela especially as leftists
we should worry about poor people
and there's none of that pin drops i
went to venezuela uh stores were empty
it was very very difficult to buy things
we went to a mall if you can call it
that and it was just a bunch of empty
stores and some were open
we did go to some areas that you know
had food there were wealthier areas
luke also went to venezuela someone was
literally shot and killed as soon as i
landed at the airport
and yeah at the airport at the airport
the airport is one of the most dangerous
places you could
be in caracas venezuela why is that uh
that's where all the major robberies and
crimes happen and an egyptian guy was
literally just just a couple of minutes
in front of me leaving the airport some
guys tried to mug him he resisted they
shot it
i heard the shot as i was going through
customs but i wanted to point crazy
venezuela
luke posted a bunch of videos of these
markets that were just barren
yeah but there were leftists american
leftists who went to venezuela and went
to the potemkin markets
and filmed all the glory of all their
products saying how great it was
the chavista areas right the communist
friendly areas that that
were of course friendly with the regime
this is what people don't realize sorry
when you go to these countries the
government runs everything they also are
perfectly happy
this happened in the 90s north korea and
many other places they're like okay
we've got enough food for 500 people
we've got uh 2 000 people who's going to
get the food
they're not going to say we're going to
do it equally they're going to take care
of their own first in a way you can't
blame them because they don't take care
of their own they're going to lose their
hold on power and therefore
not continue the revolution so from
their perspective they don't have a
choice
it's horrifying and again what we talked
about earlier americans
have no clue what this is like but my
next book's going to change are there
ways to dissolve monarchy that aren't
violent well yeah they could abdicate
decentralized
every problem we see comes from
centralization comes from big
governments comes from people
saying that they're going to fix
everyone's problems and that's
impossible we have to
realize and wake up as a people and
understand that one person shouldn't be
responsible for everyone else and we
should all be responsible for ourselves
personal responsibility yes yep or
call your friend hire someone it doesn't
you know like people are like oh in
anarchist society you'd be the first one
shot i'm like
why don't i have the ability to call in
my big mma friends
to be like hey can you uh be my
housemate well hold on hold on
if the idea was that criminal punishment
deters crimes
why do we still have crimes right we've
got very harsh problems we got what is
it like a quarter of the world's prison
population is here in the us
it's unconscionable there were several
studies that the death penalty was not a
deterrent for people committing extreme
crimes
i i look at it this way when it comes to
like gun rights specifically
i sometimes cross busy streets cars
don't hit me you know why
they have brakes surprise surprise the
individuals driving those cars don't
want to kill
somebody right it's not because of the
law it's because they don't want to kill
somebody and also let's be completely
sociopathic about it they don't want the
headache from damaging their car
so even if they don't value your life
there's still going to be a cost for
them in terms of like why do i i'd
rather the break than
having a day of having drill with his
blood it's let's let's uh it's when
people get desperate is when they change
no one really wants to hurt until
they're starving and they need
a degree and everything's in their way
there's a lot of evil people out there
who get off and hurting like children a
lot of sociopaths most of them
are in washington dc per capita the most
largest amount
this is why my new political ideology is
called marxism
and it's where we take elon musk's
starship whenever someone
we take all of congress and all the
politicians they go in the ship
and then it blasts off then what
what do you mean yeah
[Laughter]
what happens next we all live happily
ever after applause
and then what we do is whenever someone
wins a position in office
we have smaller rockets and they blast
off
so you won congratulations right this
way sir
adios let's go to super chat to serve
government
[Laughter]
it must be done i was going to bring up
tehran but uh we have chats
oh yeah yeah that's where they ban
politicians in a mexican city with 30
000 people
they ban politicians political slogans
political signs
and people deal with their problems
through a community one-on-one basis
and it's one of the largest anarchist
places in the world chiron mexico i did
a full documentary on it on my youtube
channel we are change and it's worth a
watch because the ideas expressed there
have been carried out with large
populations in a peaceful cohesive way
with people taking personal
responsibility for themselves and
standing up
to government to the cartels and to the
police officers that were all corrupted
and doing horrible things to the
community and now they're living in
peace
where literally homicides down
completely
murders stopped completely kidnapping
stopped completely all because people
decided to take their life into their
own personal hands can i give you some
unsolicited advice for you and everybody
else if you're doing something like this
get a url that would be easy to remember
so instead of going to we are changed
you just go to like iranian
documentary.com they go straight to it
so that's a cheap easy way to promote
stuff
uh i i'm really big proponent of that
all of our sponsors we do that yeah yeah
number two is uh i don't think people
are like the ancoms
they get something a lot of stuff right
because human beings are not lord of the
flies despite what we're told in
hobbsion
when you look at survivor the only
reason these people are fighting is
because they have to vote each other out
when people tend to be in communities
for the
most part which is like 90 which is a
huge percentage they really don't want
headaches they don't want conflict they
just want to get along
and like sometimes like okay my
neighbor's noisy am i really going to
call the cops even judge judy
berated one of the pla the plaintiffs or
defendants once she goes
i'm like she's like i'm 900 years old
i've had lots of neighbors some i like
some i don't like some are annoying some
are not annoying whatever i've never
called the cops in any of them
because when you're dealing in a
community you have to anyone who lives
in the city you have to have some some
little sacrifices so
i think people don't appreciate to what
extent
cooperation is the norm like you see a
kid
it's just kind of it's just taken for
granted i think let's go to super chats
the problem is you say ninety percent
but yes correct
ten percent doesn't scale properly
because if you have a hundred thousand
people that's
10 years crazies and you need law
enforcement in my opinion
well you need security and we need super
chats yes you are right
so if you haven't already smash the like
button and go to tim
become a member and help support our
work as we expand our newsroom hire more
awesome people with your support
and uh subscribe to this channel if you
haven't already share the show with your
friends so that
i just think is it wrong for me to say
that we deserve more ratings than cnn
i wouldn't say ratings more viewers more
viewers these ratings is the nielsen
thing why given nielsen the credit yeah
well
you know what i mean i don't know i i
think you i don't want to say deserve
earned
do you well what i mean is cnn gets
propped up by youtube they get put on
the front page
they get put in well they're not in
airports anymore they just are given
this they're the
i think we should have more people
watching us than watching them and other
channels as well
i i i think the vibe here is a lot more
entertaining
so uh if you agree with michael it's
entertaining share the show with your
friends
all right let's read some of these super
someone watching the show has friends
that's a good point who are you fooling
all right
scott beach says mr mouse i bought all
your books belong to your locals
community
and my only real interaction with you is
on twitter and is your polls
but you blocked me on twitter why i
don't know who you are but
i have no idea you don't know scott
beach i don't what's his username
i'm assuming it's scott beach i don't
know i don't know why i blocked you
scott scott if you're in my locals i
will unblock you there you go if you go
to
and support me sometimes it happens
accidentally too what you've never
accidentally hit the black button no
you had to confirm it don't you i don't
think you have to but it's like you have
to go with their profile then you have
to hit block then you have to yes yeah
you're correct yeah
okay well you'd have to confirm so you
purposefully shot out one of your
biggest fans i i
would say he's one of my biggest fans i
know his name
all right uh and i'll tell you why i
blocked you two
wait there's another comment that's
identical
i love that they're super chatting us
then the michael the michael angelo is
literally the same thing he said
what's his name the michael angelou is
he on locals too
and he said the exact same thing i
bought all your books belong to your
local community
and you block me on twitter is it the
same guys a verbatim to say is copy
paste
it's copy and paste but it's a different
person but it i think that's multiple
accounts i see that it's
in the church there's two super chats
that are verbatim okay i'll look into it
in my locals
reply to just yeah just reply to the
elizabeth spires thread novum says 354
more federal holidays and will meet the
end goal
malice you've changed my life for the
better i have never had so much personal
responsibility as i have now
here's the other thing what's amazing
like a federal holiday is just a
lockdown
it's just making it illegal for you to
go to work first if you have certain
jobs yeah
yeah how could could people uh
comfortably smug who was government jobs
right well covered smug was a twitter
account absolutely love oh yeah like
he's like how could someone be against
this holiday you know celebrating black
achievement juneteenth they just made a
fair holiday i'm like
because all a federal holiday is is it's
illegal for you to go to work
i don't know only only in the government
right but the banks
well the banks choose to do it sure i i
i don't know they don't if you're a
member if you're in bank i think you
have to be closed by federal holiday if
i'm not mistaken
please double check this i got a i got
an issue with juneteenth the name
it should be called like uh like uh what
do they call abolition day or like
what do they call it when that
historical name they freed the slaves on
that day right
well so the arguably the slaves were
freed with the emancipation proclamation
emancipation day
there was that's not june 19th there was
still active civil war it wasn't until
the north actually went into texas and
enforced the law
long after the war was over when people
were still
illegally holding slaves the last slave
was freed was this day celebrated
okay i'm i like it um i
i saw i think it was uh was it charlie
kirk who who tweeted that it was wrong
because it was a race based holiday or
whatever
my attitude is like we have independence
day where this ideological revolution
where we severed ourselves from the
moderators
labor day it's just the classic
following day right but that's the king
day was a regime called black people's
day
oh wow did you not know this yeah no no
so the independence day for us was when
we had this
ideological revolution and physical
revolution of sorts
and uh we we severed ourselves from
monarchy we realized that divine
providence wasn't
what makes law and then uh where 80 or
so years later
with another ideological revolution that
you cannot hold people as property and
it was
much blood was shed for this i love it
it's an independence day yeah i mean
it's a major step forward for freedom in
america so i
in terms of like like it's better than a
tree
if you ask me which of these is a more
important holiday it's going to be a
no-brainer oh yeah yeah
all right metal metal retro duchess says
luke you should make a t-shirt that says
fortified elections have consequences
that seems like a very safe term
that's a pretty good one actually it's
pretty good fortified i like that
we actually we have someone joining soon
who's we're going to expand our merch
and we're going to do merch like new
different shirts and memes
so excited yeah we got a lot of people
joining um
we're going to be really big really
really fast we just got one of the best
3d printers on the market
we're going to we're going to be making
stuff we're going to be doing uh uh for
the guests that are interested portraits
that we'll auction off to fans
are they going to be like uh like
caricatures i guess they could be well
are they or
i i don't want to keep no they were
they're meant to be regular portraits of
people on the show
you know hand drawn like someone will
have someone draw
like a guest with painting or like a
pencil like a digital painting oh
that sounds something and then we we
print it out have it signed and then we
auction it off like one of a kind
oh i like this mic we want to do a bunch
of things to expand culture to create uh
symbols
so i'll i'll try to be quick with this i
went to a
lecture on music business 15 years ago
and this guy was explaining the the
business of music is not about the song
it's about the memories
yes you create yes and he said here's
one thing that we did
we had a big set drop which is a
gigantic flag that was checkered
and after the show we cut every
checkered piece out and sold
those to the fans wow that way they
would always retain a piece
that would remind them every time they
looked at it what you need to understand
about merchandise
is not that someone is going to be
wearing a shirt not that they're
advertising your band
but that every time they open their
closet they remember that moment they
shared with you
we need that we need people to remember
the conversations remember how they felt
about them
and own something when they see that
portrait of michael malus autographed
and maybe we'll do like prints but we'll
do one autograph yeah people will have
this really cool picture and then their
friends will say what's this oh it's
this guy michael now it's got a great
book you got to read it it generates the
conversation
it keeps it insight in mind this is why
i don't have a blanket but i cover
myself with aids quilt
to remember all the people who died so
young tragically in the 80s right on
all right let's read some more eric
miller says i trolled the king of trolls
live using his own words against him as
uh as he was dressed as superman
who gets weak with rocks from his own
planet on april fool's day it was worth
gitmo good sir my respects
i love it when people create their own
little backstories
that happened and everyone clapped
that's right
all right superman if he wasn't scared
of green rocks says tim she hasn't
gotten the monkey yet she was halfway
there
and another monkey had diarrhea so now
she has to wait a week michael there is
still time
i don't cassandra i love you i'm in love
with you you know this
listen i no i can sit down and talk
about animals for literally days
let's come up with a better exotic sugar
glider yes
those are possums that you that like to
be in your pocket
they're adorable they're monkey shaped
in size they're in and they smell nice
because they only eat fruit
there's the males have a bald spot they
rub it on things that make it smell like
banana
they're amazing pets it's so much better
and their life span is shorter
there's and they have little hands where
their their fingers are are stuck
together because they try to climb
things
there's so much and you could throw them
like a ball because they glide so you
throw it to your daughter you throw it
back and they float yes they glide they
glide
look it up sugar gliders it would it not
only is it going to attempt the price
it's going to be pleasure instead of
headache as the monkey bites your
beautiful child the marmoset would do
that yes they're nasty
hmm i'm so ready for this i want a sugar
glider now
they're great they're domesticated why
not a dog we'll have to call cassandra
that's too basic yeah i can understand
she wants something weird yeah
all right uh stalin
uh cepatus says hi tim i love your show
you need to defeat cnn
telemundo and univision are worse than
cnn greetings from dominican republic
ian you're awesome
well they're worse because when they
talk about covid at the very beginning
they have the upside-down exclamation
point
so it really gets scary oh yeah yeah
spanish
all right jayrich says holy crap how did
you guys manage to get the cash cab guy
on best episode
ever knock knock i'm a gorilla just
kidding though michael is awesome can't
wait for his show
yeah you were on cash cab i was did you
win he did pretty well
all i do is win baby i sent you the
video it was pretty entertaining yeah
that's great what was that was the
what's the driver's name do you remember
ben bailey yeah was he like shocked how
smart you were
oh you want the cash cap story yeah yeah
when i am someone is trapped in a
situation with me
i'm gonna do whatever i can to get them
to break so i was messing with him
the entire time uh i was just talking
about like how did you get on cash cab
i'm like i got my knee pads i met the
producers like
just really things and i'm like what are
they gonna edit in and where they're
gonna edit out
and the very last thing was double or
nothing right it's like a video bonus
round
and at that point we had two out of
three strikes and your adrenaline is
through the roof
and you're like i just want this to be
done so because if you get the three
strikes you lose all of it
so like i just want to get to my
location get the money and then he's
like
you know we have this thing called
double dot they gotta go okay we're just
gonna take the money and he goes
can you just sit and pretend that you're
thinking about it for a second
and we take it taped it again as soon as
i left the cash cab they give you fake
money they really give you a check later
and i turn to the cat they go what are
you gonna do money i go this is all
going up my nose
because i saw something behind the music
about like aerosmith or motley crue
they're like where'd you get your money
that goes
all about my nose that got cut
[Music]
so he was not having a good day with me
as
literally the backseat driver just
clowning him the whole time
horrible person and i love it we enjoy
your presence i know
[Laughter]
all right let's see uh josh shepard says
does tim kessler have a tip line slash
contact for news or stories just the tip
i lip just just i live just outside of
portland asking for a friend
we don't right now that's a good idea
we'll make one for now pitches at
timcast.com is a good way to do it just
buy tipcast.com
tip tip yeah get it quick someone's
gonna get it because someone's buying it
right now i just told people to buy they
bought it dude just the ticket
dot com oh i think i think mike mike
that's actually a good idea for a tip
one clever
although i don't know if people would
take it seriously all right
the one free man says anything
successful is racist they don't want you
to be successful or global
warming those are the two they alternate
yes also the state label
labels patrons as terrorists because the
one enemy of a patriot is a corrupt
tyrannical government
well the founding fathers were
terrorists they were all uh
revolutionaries
literally that's what king george called
them don't tell the back the blue crowd
what they did
okay uh i can't are the iran crowd yeah
i can't read cyrillic
but they say we can't you can't i can
can you
i can but very poorly it says it's like
an i i can't even describe what the
letters are yeah
backwards are probably uh it's a
backwards a
e backwards a r e i can't
uh two backwards ends i do understand
that eating eggs fresh from the
chicken's butt
is just eating cicadas with a few extra
steps don't you
yeah they're asking me no no i think
they're just saying it go back to russia
so so i tweeted with your cicada food i
tweeted yesterday i had
eggs fresh from the chicken's butt and
today i had a tomato fresh off the vine
city folk be missing out yeah so that's
what that's in reference to yeah we
definitely don't have uh
eggs and tomatoes in the city look i
don't i don't i have a filtration system
for cicadas
okay i'm not going to eat a cicada put
them in i filter it through the chicken
and the chicken turns it into an egg and
then i cook the egg with some chili
powder and some some
peppers and it's delicious there this is
being made into one of those videos
where they edit everything and make us
have funny reactions
right now that little clip what's the
pink trip he's doing that right now i
hope so
uh yeah we got chickens only one lays
eggs because she was a re-home the other
one's
the their it turns out the r we thought
it was a transgender uh uh chicken it
turned out to actually just been a
rooster who was assigned female at birth
and that was an error on the part of the
hatchery
so now he's got like they're getting
older
and the rooster has like his favorite
girls they're like the bigger ones i
guess that's what he's into
and then they all well it's like it is i
don't need to do chicken or whatever
but he'll he'll walk over and lay down
and then like his two favorite girls
come and lay with him
and then the other girls run up and they
lay on the outside and the one rehome
just stands in the corner with its wings
out going
like just freaking out life is really
good when you have a favorite girl
yeah right that's right all right let's
see
special taxi says i've been a long time
supporter of both you and malice
love it when the dear leader is on tim
castle dear writer
also very happy that luke is back don't
you guys ever get tired of winning
uh i'll let you know when that happens
yeah sometimes try to make it as
challenging as possible
yeah so it's rewarding you know you know
what i i i've been
let me just put it this way um in
response to winning all the time
it's not that i'm winning all the time
it's that i don't really view winning
and losing as different things
so like uh when i skate for instance and
i fall
i don't look at it like i failed it's
just
the same exact thing to me but landing
it is like
reaching the goal you know i guess i
kind of view it like everything we do
whether it works or doesn't work is just
a part of the process
can i also thank the audience from the
bottom of my heart like people
it's really kind of very sick and by
design i would guess that like
like urban media elites make it a point
that if you're experiencing
it's trying to express kindness or uh uh
gratitude
that they have to have some sneer or
that is somehow inferior to like
complaints
uh i i'm in a different position as an
author
because i can't tell you i can it's
going to be under 10. how many
book projects i had that failed because
you write the proposal
you have a very big shot agent he shops
it around and to there's like seven
houses
and if none the editors want it that
book proposal is dead
now because of this anarchist handbook
and other books
i don't need to get that editor's
approval i could put this out
maybe it sells crap but it still exists
i've still
from concept to execution so that is a
major thing that's happened only in the
last five years
right on all right so thank you
in the the super chat says in the
greater seattle area there's been a lot
of military aircraft and helicopters
it may just be a reserve weekend but i'm
way more aware of it
interesting i see what what's going on
with russia and china and i'm
i'm pessimistic in the short term
optimistic in the long term but i think
you know
were you the one who was uh bearish on
fourth turning stuff and through city
strap or
oh i heard it's through kitty's is how
you pronounce his name
i think it's through kitty it's in greek
interesting that makes sense because
they don't have the cc yeah yeah yeah
yeah that sound yeah
the is i i that wasn't me that you're
referring to you don't like the word
i don't know what that means that is
it's it's the it's the straws how
generational oh i don't like that stuff
i hate that stuff
yeah it seems to astrology to me
all right mr hunt first name michael
says
illegal immigrants pouring over the
border political prisoners in solitary
confinement
china is ramping up for war with the u.s
why aren't we trying harder
why can't you and other news guys start
a movement for secession
well i don't think secession would help
us in a war with china well make
everything
first of all you guys who is this guy's
name um his last name is hunt and his
first name is mike
okay listen mr hunt if that is your real
name
tells me it's not in 2015 i was the one
who wrote
the article about it's time to disunite
the states i was the first one calling
for the secession stuff
jessie kelly was second so please don't
point fingers when you don't you were
talking about yeah and i was with the
idea of not even knowing that you were
even talking about it the first time i
went on the show it was the first idea i
brought up i was like we need a peaceful
divorce
because it makes sense to avoid a lot of
the bigger drama and fighting that is
going to happen and is going to be ugly
i have been saying this for 10 years the
entire time yeah but nobody else is
totally woman in politics come on now
let's have some sense
it's about time we start i think so
right i agree and that woman's name is
marjorie taylor green
well she wants to abolish the atf i know
i know it's great
i just wanted atf agents
all right dilly dilly says thank you
luke for addressing canadian gestapo
style police not enough discussion about
it up here
luke please don't leave right away but
someone followed up immediately
uh please leave right away says to
everyone that's begging luke to stay you
all do know he has his own channel right
and it's pretty damn good it's called we
are change
that's right i'm very close to seven
hundred thousand youtube subscribers
that's true yeah that's amazing it's
amazing especially with me confronting
the head of alphabet before at
bilderberg and pissing him off and
chasing him down the street
so i'm very lucky and very blessed and i
i can't thank you guys enough for being
a part of it and making me better by
by constantly criticizing me correctly
correctly
you do amazing work dude this is this is
for you michael
stoker roilett says tim and company love
your show i've had a monkey as a pet
worst decision i've ever made the only
thing the monkey did was constantly
continuously through an unrelenting
never-ending stream of excrement at me
bad time in my life i don't think
marmosets do that though
yes they do oh why would marmosets be
different
monkeys you gotta call her monkey
they're just small monkeys i gotta tell
the story so um
what what in brazil right is that what
it is yeah
i was in rio and we were walking down
the street when i got hit by something
and i like turned around like what
happened and the guy was like he's okay
he's just a monkey and i was or he said
he i think he said macaque
and i was like what excuse me
i got hit by something and he said it's
just a it's just a macaque
and then i i didn't know what it meant i
didn't think he said he hit me with yeah
yeah yeah you know
and then he was like look up there and
then i look and there was a little
monkey on top of like a a bus
like seating thing and it was like
looking at us and it yelled and it threw
something at me again
it was just the most hilarious thing
i've ever seen they're all over rio i
guess they just run around and do their
thing you know but if you look at a
monkey's energy
they're very frenetic they're always
looking around they're bouncing around
it's not something that should be in
this small space that you would give
like let's suppose a sugar glider or
something else that's cool yeah they
need to swing through trees
and and they're smart enough to know
you're the one keeping me prisoner here
yeah i experienced them in thailand
and in india and then both times their
their gangster and their
their trouble yes all right let's see
leguma says i met an anti-trump
i met an anti-trump leftist with a cast
still on their arm from being pulled
from the path of the car in
charlottesville by a right-wing
militiamen who saved them
they fully debunked the good people on
both sides hoax can i email
email you their name and youtube this
person is a patriot interesting uh
pitches
timcast.com
all right christopher says tim your
ignorance to the law is amazing
sometimes if a crime is committed with a
gun they never give the guns back
yeah but it's it's not necessarily it's
not necessarily a crime that of the gun
that they're being charged with right uh
well
my point is if he won and didn't plead
guilty then it wasn't a crime yeah then
they'd get his guns back
how could you be like well you know
you're not guilty of committing a crime
but we're gonna take it because it was a
crime
but sometimes they do that like drug
stuff like if you're not convicted they
still keep the stuff
yeah yeah yeah yeah so we don't know how
the law works evil state stuff man yeah
all right or they could be like we lost
it boogaloo boy says rip boy
you you don't you want me to no but you
know what the book i mean
yeah but it's the super chat and they
said rip duncan limp time to raise the
black flag
uh is near stay safe and stay deadly who
is duncan you wait that story deserves a
lot more attention i talked about it
no knock raid in the middle of the night
in maryland from a police department
a swat department in maryland that's
known for having many controversial no
knock raids
and as you were describing and a man was
shot when he was sleeping
through the window his pregnant
girlfriend was ripped
ripped away through glass and you know
no one really talks about the story but
this is a huge story and they're
refusing to release the body cam footage
yeah whoa and oh none the cops are going
to be charged and he's dead
yeah and here's the thing here's the
thing let's let's steal man this
argument
let's pretend because the argument was
he got a tip he's got like a red flag
gun law
you got a guy who's got an illegal and
he's like he's like a really evil person
who's killed kids before whatever just
let's let's make him as worse possible
who shouldn't have these guns you know
he's armed
you know there's a girl in there and he
was with his parents i believe you know
there's people there
you stake out that house you wait until
he leaves to go to
7-eleven you knock on the door where mom
and the girlfriend go
here's our warrant get the f out our way
we're going to search this house from
attic to basement we're going to tear
apart the furniture but you get to be
alive and you go stand in the corner
everyone including the gun people would
be like
if you have if i have to choose between
these two scenarios i'm choosing this
one
the idea of a no knock i i said this
line on glenn beck and i'll say it again
i'll say it till i'm dead in the face
even stalin had the courtesy to knock
you laugh but think about it i know even
the kgb
germany you're at night you're terrified
because
oh my god it's two in the morning
they're coming to take us to the gulag
the fact that you could shoot guns
blazing for an american
who might have guns it's not like he has
some if look if he has
he had a kid if he had a kid hostage if
this is an imminent terror threat
i could wrap my head around it very very
easily what was their claim against him
that he had guns they shouldn't have he
had some red flag law yeah
wow yeah yeah this so this was executed
there was not even a claim
that he was an imminent threat to anyone
right so the premise behind no knock
raids
let's also explain it because it sounds
so psychotic is
we have to do these because otherwise
the person might destroy the evidence
now
i can even wrap my head if it's a coke
dealer and he's going to flush the coke
down the toilet why they don't just shut
off the water in that case doesn't make
sense to me
and is really risking these officers
lives where they're okay you can still
flush toilets
sure the point is you're not flushing
those guns down the toilet
you cannot destroy an armada an arsenal
of guns
in even a long period of time yeah and
these people
are murderers and by the way this is why
i say all cops are criminals
how much money would it take gretchen
whitmer to tell you
to put on body armor and at three in the
morning
shoot someone in their sleep or break
down their door
while they're in bed at age twenty three
very yeah
with their pregnant girlfriend if you
can take any kind of money do that you
are a monster
all right charles
says welcome to tim pool bets everyone
demand a jury trial the state can't
process all of us
convicts strong together don't bend the
knee let's go
crackbot says tim aren't you the one
saying the kenosha kid was going to get
life in prison so what makes you think
that they would get a fair trial
uh i'm not entirely convinced they would
there's a lot of people politically
fighting on their behalf
i do think uh the kenosha kid will
likely get life in prison on these
charges
i still think he needs to fight and not
plead guilty imagine if kyle retinas was
like
i'm gonna plead guilty to felony assault
with a deadly weapon instead of two two
counts of murder because at least then
he'll only go for 25 years
nah he needs to fight he needs to win
and he needs all the support he can get
i i tim i also think it's very hard for
maybe for me maybe not for you because
you've actually
been arrested when you're in that
environment i think it's very very hard
to think rationally
and i think the longer you spend in that
prison the more you think this is going
to be this is what i'm looking at for
the rest of my life
i i can't do this i can't do this i'll
take whatever i can like like a rad and
a sinking ship
that's what i imagine is psychology for
a lot of these people and i don't blame
them it's
just by design it's dehumanizing and
it's it's torture too especially if
you're in solitary confinement which a
lot of people are
i will stress this about about kyle to
make sure i'm clear
i wish none of that ever happened it's
it's it's a horrifying tragedy and i
think any violence that comes from the
state afterwards is just making
everything worse
so at this point i hope there's a fair
trial and
we'll see what comes of it but we've had
we've had what four or five witnesses in
here telling us about what happened
and we even had destiny he's a a leftist
he said it was the clearest case of
self-defense he'd ever seen and he got
banned on twitch for saying that
he got removed from their partner
program so anyway look
i think you you won't always get uh a
fair trial but
i think if enough people stood up and
demanded their rights we could have an
impact before it's too late
yeah i think you're right that it
instills panic and that we almost need
some sort of like military training to
stay
calm in the face of authority or just be
from eastern europe
we got a really really big super chat i
was retracted it was 500 bucks
so but but you can retract super chats
yeah
no no the the message was deleted the
super chats who did it by
i don't know if i should read it because
they took their their their their
comments right does they start with g
no okay no it's a long nothing
wow thank you man that's soda money um
uh fuddrucker three thousand that's not
actually the worst of the fuddruckers
well that's not the name they actually
put though yeah the name is the other
one yeah uh i had the opportunity to be
on a local trial twice
first time it was heavily implied that a
child was abused second it was clearly
about attempted murder
jury nullification isn't as simple as
liberals dream it to be
yeah us liberals you know i've i've uh i
don't think i'd ever get chosen for a
jury
ever because i have like a uh i have a
policy of
i will almost always say not guilty in
almost every circumstances
someone who shall remain nameless when
they're doing jury selection
went up to them and said i'm an
anarchist and i will not vote to convict
under any circumstances and they said
too bad you're on the grand jury and i'm
like or whoever that person was
was like all right let's see what let's
dance i'd absolutely say uh i will not
convict
uh well i say 99 look if they come and
they're like here's a video of him
beating a child to death i'd be like and
whoever this person was certainly did
convict because there there are cases
where it's like weed
but there's also cases like this guy
tied up his adopted mom and and raped
and killed her it's like okay this is
not uh anarchist versus
right right this is this person should
not be on the streets ever again but i
would i would inform them like unless
you can present
not just evidence beyond a reasonable
doubt but like clear evidence
proving guilt my personal philosophy is
jury nullification and advocacy of to
all other jurors so i'm more than happy
to be on your jury
to advocate to all the other jurors how
we can nullify this discharge
yeah and if they say okay oh cool i'm
down i'm not trying to fight you i'm
telling you my philosophy so you know
yeah and if they want me on there so be
it you know and we all know
also know homer simpson's advice on how
to get our jury duty which one was that
uh to say you're prejudicing and still
racist
uh so phoenix gold says tim's crossfire
idea malice and
vosh it would leave me speechless you
know the rest uh vosh is agreed to come
back on are you familiar with vosh
no oh somewhat isn't he like a socialist
yeah i think he's a socialist
he's a prominent leftist youtube
personality and i told him i would love
to have him come back with with another
person but i don't want it to be an
unfair kind of ambush
so if if i got like the foremost leading
expert
on some field to come in between two
commentators that would
like i'm not i'm not all about that so i
said if there's someone you want to
bring that you know he's like i'm not i
don't think it matters you know let me
know and so
i started reaching out to a few people i
thought would be would be good to have
you know what i really would like to do
is
people who are clearly at odds in the
political spectrum but focus on subject
matter that doesn't cross cross over
right okay
so you know finding someone who's maybe
a bitcoiner libertarian to talk with
someone who's like a critical race
theorists
or like have that discussion where it's
like they cl
they don't tweet about each other but
here we are we'll find some agreement on
something and disagreements on other
things
so that that's what i'm thinking about
with you know inviting uh vosh back
uh obviously critical race theory is one
of the bigger components because of
what's happening today
what an advocate of that yeah yeah okay
so we we had a conversation
with him here and i think i'll put it
this way actually
i had a conversation on facebook today
someone posted a meme that was actually
really critical of critical race theory
and the leftists didn't know that they
posted an anti-critical race theory meme
and then argued with me about it because
they thought it was pro-critical race
through so it said
it was a woman saying would you like to
learn the history of racism in the
united states and i said watch out she
could be teaching critical race theory
the joke is the left comes in and says
we're just teaching about
racism but watch out it's actually
racist identitarianism or indoctrination
but they these leftists genuinely
thought critical race theory
was literally just history and so when i
said professor chris wallace said
right during the debate and so when i
when i countered and said here's an
example of what they're teaching in
schools
it was it was an article from the
sacramento school board arguing for
creating white racial identity groups
i said i don't know how we we're better
serving our children by telling them to
form white racial humanitarian groups
and they said what are you talking about
this post is about teaching history
and i said you didn't say history you
said critical race theory and they were
like i don't think you know what you're
talking about
and i said i just sent you a link to
this thing they're teaching in schools
that white people should have a white
racial awakening
and should form groups of only white
people to discuss their race
and i said let me ask you a question if
you believe that white people
are are colonizers do you think that
putting a bunch of white people together
and telling them to discuss their racial
identity would result in
more or less racism from these people
and they were like well i think they'll
learn the right lesson and become good
people
and i was like is that why the alt-right
became so prominent for the amount of
time they did because learning about
racial identitarianism made them
peaceful anti uh racist or something
i think it just told them to form racial
identity groups which they did
whether it's positive or negative is
irrelevant but that's what they
genuinely believe so vosh uh i i don't
put words in his mouth at this point but
i think during the conversation was
generally of the opinion
that critical race theory is simply an
academic theory analyzing the
intersection of race and policy
which it's not that's what they claim it
to be but when you actually
look at what they say and they talk
about race as property
it's martin bailey it's it's a racial
identitarian ideology
which uh so i'll put it this way
critical race theory is the academic
theory based in racial identitarianism
that that's there you go so when they
come and say it's just a theory say
sure sure but the theory that forms this
the the ideology that forms these
theories is a perception of racial
identitarianism as being paramount
i i oppose racial and and identitarian
we've only had you have to you're mixed
race
well it's nowhere for you to go right so
that's what i tell people
the world has existed as an identitarian
civilization since the dawn of time
we've only had 56 years
of an attempt at anti-identitarian law
yeah critical race theory seeks to
reimpose
this is a reactionary ideology they
oppose the revolution that we had 56
years ago it's not even been
uh people are still alive my family
still alive who went through
identitarian laws that exactly what the
critical race theory seek to impose
they want to undo the hard work that my
family many many others did
and it's very very simple i don't
understand you know these people this
guy i'm arguing he's a white guy
and i was like you are a white man
telling a mixed-race person that you
seek to impose law based on race which
would
cause extreme harm to my family of
course i oppose you yeah
and they say well shut up we don't care
yeah of course yeah
so that's why i talk about the way i do
if people are interested in this james
lindsay was on my show you guys had him
on
yeah he's great me and him go back and
forth for an hour
really getting into the details of this
so if you go on youtube uh
james lindsey michael mouse you can find
that it's it's one of my best episodes
what's the metaphor of martin bailey you
brought up oh so mont bailey i talked
about this in the new right it's a
technique it's a
very common once you identify it you
can't not see it see it everywhere where
you have basically the mod and the
bailey i forget which is which you have
the castle and then you have the grounds
right
i believe the mott is the hill the hill
okay so basically what they'll happen is
no
are you sure that's kind of secondary
okay so they'll have
a premise which is indisputable then
they'll have a premise which is
ridiculous right so be like
okay um we need to eradicate racism in
america and have people to be treated
fairly okay i'll agree with that then
you agree
that people who are economic minorities
should go to college for free i'm like
oh
what but you just but you just agreed
that we need to eradicate racism so they
just vacillate
between they get you to agree to
something that you can't not disagree
with
then they extrapolate that to what they
think is organic and when you argue with
the extrapolation
they retreat back into the area of
agreement
as if that premise therefore covers what
they're extrapolating to
you said the mott was the head i think i
thought you're correct
the bailey is the open field the mod is
the hill where the keep is on top
and so yes so that's what they were
doing they're like saying
i want to explore the history of
politics and race in america
that's extremely germane everyone wants
that's very fascinating what was it like
being black in new york in the 1700s i
would love to know
right so therefore we need to critical
races well no no no
i'm not for that well you just said i
think it's the other way around actually
what they'll do is they'll say
we need racial identitarian law and
affirmative action and then when you say
i think it's wrong that you're telling a
child
simply by looking the way you do you
don't get to go to harvard and they say
what are you talking about we're just
trying to teach the history of racism
yeah exactly
exactly and that's exactly what they did
so my response to this guy's critical
race they may not even do it
intentionally
they're just trained to see these things
synonymous so uh but i do think i got i
got through some of these people because
um i think a lot of them genuinely don't
understand what they're talking about
they just watch cnn and then believe the
lies
and so my response was the training
you you have to use the the socratic
method you don't i don't approach these
people as enemies i simply agree with
them
when they say when they post this meme i
just immediately was like
i think teaching children in schools to
form white racist
groups is a bad idea and then when
they're like what are you talking about
here's a link yeah and then they read it
and they go i don't understand and i'll
be like
that's what they're teaching in these
schools and then we get into an argument
because they want to defend their tribe
but eventually
i said ultimately the end of the
conversation i was like it sounds like
we agree
that i think we need to teach the true
history of racism and colonization
like everybody knows christopher
columbus didn't discover america there
were already people here and he didn't
even land in america anyway
but you could argue to the europeans it
was the first time europeans had contact
so i think understanding that context is
very important now i think we also agree
telling a bunch of white kids to form a
group based on just being white and
discover their right racial identity
probably not a good thing right like
well of course great here's the
literature
here's what they're saying you know it's
really it's really amazing how
the leftists will accuse conservatives
of not knowing anything about
credibility yeah yeah
and i'm like well perhaps the the what's
being argued because i'll i'll say this
i could have done a way better job in my
discussion with vosh for sure
but when we talk about critical race
theory there are certain very obvious
grievances and things that are happening
that we're concerned about
i'm not complaining about derrick bell
writing some literature
i don't care about his opinions i'm not
complaining about
ebro max kendy writing a book he's
allowed to write a book what i'm
complaining about is applied
critical theory and i think one of the
problems that conservatives have
if they keep saying critical race there
and over and over again and that is
the left's battleground they immediately
then say oh well
here's kimberly crenshaw we don't teach
kimberly crunch on schools
what they're doing is applied racial
theory or what they call
they call it critical race praxis so
what happens is
they take the theories turn it into an
indoctrination
and then slip it into every subject so
when you say critical race theory the
immediate response is
i don't think we've had a lecture on
derek bell once in fifth grade that's
absurd
and you're like that's not what i'm
talking about that's what critical race
theory is
so all right let's read a couple more
here buttertoe says
reno may posted a video today about a
cali police department that illegally
took high-capacity magazines from a guy
that could legally own them then
proceeded to tell the owner that even if
a court order was given he wouldn't get
them back
yep criminal yep yep i'm pretty sure
that's like
just stealing yeah it is yeah yeah
the state's doing it so it's fine right
all right uh we'll do two more
have you ever heard of taxes yeah
delano manuel says michael i just joined
your locals i came across the auto
autobiography of ukrainian immigrant
alexander sas
jaworski i'll post more details on your
locals feed
okay thank you and uh just in line with
the last conversation
uh samuel harris says tim hi samuel
harris
v samuel harris uh tim how do you
respond to people who call you white or
white passing in order to shut you shut
down your opinion in discussions around
race do you pee pee in their coke
uh i i immediately i immediately start
screaming
my lungs i call them racist over and
over again
and i say racist said what racist says
what
so i've had this happen to me many times
and
i uh one of the issues is it is a big
excuse
and then i say like well i get i get it
from uh
my whole life people told me that i was
mexican white people tend to say i'm
mexican
people who aren't white tend to say i'm
white so what am i supposed to do
i don't exist in any of their worlds i'm
always in other
people there are some places where i
blended perfectly i was in egypt and
they were like
you don't got to worry about a thing
people think people will think you're
egyptian and i was able to walk but
here's here's the other thing
15 years ago i remember this is on the
real world there's a character
piggy i think was even her name was real
with london i'm thinking
there was so much hand-wringing about
mixed-race people
and how they don't fit in anywhere and
there's girls who are like half black
half white and the black girls
tell them they're too white and the
white girls are racist and we need to
represent have more representation of
multiracial people when you have the
census
what am i supposed to check off my dad's
you know chinese and my mom's hispanic
there's no box for me
and this was a big conversation it's a
big move about leftism and now that you
have the crt thing
it's just like yeah we don't care about
that that was just like that's an excuse
i mean no no they
i've i've straight up had these crt
people like essentially tell me
that i'm uh uh a chopped liver i'm i'm a
second-class citizen
during occupy wall street they said two
effing bad it is for us and not for you
yeah and i'm like we're the smallest
minority in the country not only that
we're not cohesive
someone who's like you know uh black and
asian is very different looking from
someone who's white and asian
or who's hispanic and you know middle
eastern or something
i'm like not only are we the smallest
minority but in our own individual
groups we're even smaller for a minority
and they say
we don't care yeah that's what at occupy
wall street they told me to just go
screw myself yeah
they said you get to go leave leave
you're not part of this you don't get a
group
you don't get advocacy no one's going to
support you right and i was like well
then screw you guys
i'm going home yeah and i'll make my own
with with blackjack
with blackjack that's right just
blackjack though all right yeah just
blackjack
gotta be legal ladies and gentlemen if
you haven't already give give that like
button a good smash and subscribe to
this channel but make sure you go to
timcast.com become a member
because we're going to talk about some
kooky conspiracy nonsense i was reading
a post on 4chan and i had a good i was
like i was like this is a great sci-fi
film
seriously it's a really good sci-fi film
and people generally believe this stuff
uh so we're going to talk about that
should be up around 11. you can follow
us on facebook and instagram at tim cast
irl help share our videos
so that we can leverage these networks
to get more people to go to timcast.com
you can follow me personally at tim cast
basically everywhere this show is live
monday friday at 8 00 pm
michael uh you have a book do you want
to shout anything out anarchist
anarchisthanbook.com and i'm michael
malus on twitter and
uh yeah this book wouldn't have been
such a huge success without you guys
and without you guys so having that
you know what it's like when you have
that freedom to create what you want
and you can pay your rent yeah it's and
and given my personality
it's going to be a really fun 2021.
it's a beautiful feeling it is may you
live in interesting times
that's also a curse you know i know yeah
yeah that's right and just so people
know
i am posting very inappropriate memes
during the show
on twitter and instagram yeah i have an
airplane
i've been tweeting up a story uh all
under luke we are changed luke we are
changed twitter and instagram and
my cult is going very well you may or
may not be able to join it
on lukeuncensored.com oh i really want
to give a shout out to that book michael
that's awesome that's really cool so
much and i love the cover we didn't talk
about the cover on air
it's some sort of vapor how did you
describe it i didn't describe it ian
okay so it's like a vaporwave looking
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's just cool style
that's why i started the cover
john gerges did this cover he also did
my theme song from my for my uh
uh podcast what i did with this cover
this is what i realized
everything that we as old like very
online people are used to
corporations haven't thought of doing it
yet so vaporwave which is like this like
18
1980s miami look yeah which has it's
like it's been been there done that on
the internet like 2017
yawn but i knew no corporate publisher
would have a cover that looks like this
because that's percolated yet
so i would be able to have a cover like
this that no one else had and it would
really pop from the screen and i'm
ecstatic with it and this is lewis ling
who was the he was the first che guevara
he was the big stud of anarchy and we
gave him a little dynamite lapel pin
oh very nice i love it thank you guys so
much yeah i have never accidentally
switched to my own camera before so
there's time for everything i apologize
for that but i am actually here in the
corner you guys can follow me on twitter
at sour patch lids
as i attempt to surpass sour patch kids
and followers
oh i love serving oh and i surpassed
today the libertarian party
they're going to have to have you on
this press secretary now oh i'm going to
oh it's going to be great
this is going to be fun so make sure
you're at timcast.com uh
in about an hour or so to watch the
bonus segment and we'll see you all
there
you